fight it and we'll do it live well -
alive [ __ ] it we'll do it live that will
go down in history right it's one of the
all-time la hissy fits versus remixes -
did you ever see the Bill O'Reilly remix
the dance reacts I was amazed by that
with Bill O'Reilly where he was going no
I don't they're going yeah we're gonna
that's what we're gonna do I don't know
what that means to play us out know what
it means to play us so angry yeah so
angry yeah he's an angry man we were
talking before the podcast started about
some no no no being at Fox for years I
can't I'll let it go talk about Moby
though right yeah we could talk about
moby moby says he has like inside
information about donald trump that he
knows that donald trump talked to the
Russians first of all when you look at
Moby with his [ __ ] hashtag vegan
t-shirt on do you really think anybody
in the Russian [ __ ] intelligence
community is talking to Moby actually it
would be a brilliant ploy from the
Russians they just give a little info to
Moby like you go you tell them and he's
going to do it you know you shouldn't
definitely leak this information it
would be the downfall then they found
out he wasn't Enya and they made a
mistake hee-hee my mom was the wardrobe
stylist so costumes on her first show
called Lee Korea it's like the
french-canadian sort of Letterman like
kind of like Graham Norton in England so
they'd have stars come in all the time
and Moby was there he was just a head
case the guy was just absolutely out of
his mind nothing was good enough and he
would want something and then say he
wanted to change it like what kind of
things did he want to change I don't
know I can tell you this there were only
two people who made my mom like come
home crying one was Brett Butler and
she's like they're from Chris under fire
what she was all peeled out of her head
yeah the 90s yeah she was - my mom she
was the Wardrobe person you might have
even if you did one of the galas and I
never did the gals cuz I they wanted me
to work cleaned they put you in the
nasty show that was on my own shows
after a while I do my own shows but the
the Gallo they were always like you have
to be clean like not interested yeah I
understand being clean for Canadian TV
for no money
thanks though with a flipside is the
nasty show like just don't market it
that way just make make the show you
know what they liked it like that was
they would go to see it and it would be
like the way that the festival would
sort of differentiate I don't know I'm
not the worst name for a show I guess it
just seems like it just seems like like
they're little kids in the schoolyard
like we know comedians you know they're
it's gonna be a raw show dirty people
nasty speaking of nasty we are gentlemen
today and we have pipes oh yeah because
crowder had a router we just start
talking steven crowder who's from louder
with Crowder's internet show and he has
a thing on his internet show we have
like a little pipe rack I got trolley
would you call the trolleys a pipe rack
pipe rack okay I wanted to come up with
a better name you wanna cover that her
name Lisa so you went to Mister Rogers
neighborhood right away so I saw it I
said I always wanted to smoke a pipe man
I just think they smell good yeah have
you know that that's actually from my
brother out there that's called a
seersucker yeah your brother's a serious
pipe he knows more than I do
yeah so this isn't this like a
seersucker is a type of suit I know
that's what they call it
oh they called this like all kinds of
weird names like Lane one Q is really
common
it smells actually really it smells
really nice and the English blends which
he smokes that's we don't do that now
super heavy nicotine but like a lot of
Kia you get some Parikh it's very smoky
like incense he barbecue II I have some
done kill done he'll nightcap which'll
it'll put you to sleep so how much do
you put in the kite so yes no here's the
rule so okay we're gonna do is put it up
to the brim up to the brim just kind of
the brim hack it in there no no don't
pack it in yet okay the general rule is
the first when you tamp it down with
your finger the strength of a child then
you fill it again the strength of a
woman and you fill it a third time with
the strength of a man okay yeah just
barely now a little more strength of a
woman well what kind of a woman man like
a Chris cyborg man like a cyber let's
not talk about that because that can go
sideways in this show okay woman it's
already gone sideways back when I said
her name she's like candy man I'm gonna
than a man what kind of a man like a
Mobe man or like me
I'm Sam well not gay Jared just is
armwrestling Courtney who's like super
CrossFit extraordinaire girl weak well
she's really strong she likes going on
265 whoa that's a lot but I think he's
gonna smoke her in the armwrestling so
why do you think that I hope people can
tune in to watch I think he's a man so
yeah she thinks he's gonna win - Wow
but the bet is like 74 yeah so you tamp
that down tamp it okay like what you
want us to be a little springy okay a
little spring you there yeah a little
springy running on Moss proud yes yes
exactly
okay and then what you do is you light
at once and that's what we call the
charring light so we're gonna do is you
gonna see that already turning me on by
the way only to the actual in that Piper
it'll ruin the briar let's just meet me
at first close we eat in there it'll
[ __ ] it up
well you won't be able to taste the
tobacco from there forward yeah because
it'll taste like something around in a
circle so I don't want you to do it gosh
and then you're gonna see that tobacco
kind of raised up so puff it keep
puffing on it yeah and then you tamp it
down one more time once it goes out and
then you light it again
okay so it's super involved I know it is
it's it's not some one thing it's not
something just kind of light and go and
it won't last long
hold up immediate head rush by the way
really don't hail it just puff it do it
well how about pot smoker bro well I
don't want to heal that there's no
filter on that what are you buzzer you
well I'm saying that's like you'll get
actual chunks of tobacco on your lungs
there's no filter that's a big big maybe
you will well not me bro
probably you toss the mattress over you
bro but smell that though that smell
nice do I use a lighter can I use a
light as long as it's not a jet lighter
cuz that'll damage the briar so like I
said it's not a I like it I feel like a
distinguished gentleman like who's that
uh Nigel fronts no no he's not
distinguished he's an [ __ ] but he's a
lot of fun he's fun to listen to him
talk to people I love when you guys had
that thing when he was thug life yeah
the thug life thing it was
laris ruin not gay Jared came over and
gave you a lap dance and none of the
coin you guys are getting silly yeah we
got word that no I don't like that show
I don't know how true it is but well you
guys are one of the very few I mean
you're a conservative guy but I would
say you get a bad rap dude you really do
yes one of the reasons why I like you is
because you are you're a pretty much
fact oriented guy when it comes to a lot
of issues political issues social issues
you don't [ __ ] and you don't you
don't like try to sway things toward one
side or the other when it's not accurate
well it's not v appreciate that and by
the way these you know these probably
will go out you have to relight it
because it's just kind of an art so but
I've had people talk to me about you and
they give me this [ __ ] take on you
and I know he's a smart guy I go he's
just yeah he's conservative so yeah I
know a lot of people that are liberal
too and yeah and a lot of people that
are in the middle but you can't talk to
someone because they [ __ ] that and
that's it not to kiss Ashley but people
out there need to know that Joe has been
incredibly fair and very kind mind the
scenes you have like because they're you
have every reason not to and I think a
big reason of it honestly here's a good
example the Young Turks and we've seen
this transition with Trump or people who
are really afraid to speak out now
you're seeing that change online because
the establishment has been Barack Obama
so kids who were raised for eight years
under Bush man a bush you know listen to
no effects go to the Vans Warped Tour
whatever it is and now they've been
raised under Obama for eight years and
all this political correctness is run
amok and they're rejecting that so for
the longest time you know I had a small
youtube channel and I was on Fox I was
kind of muzzled a little bit because I
was there and there were certain things
I could say or couldn't say on line
because it was a youngish at the time as
well
take you seriously fresh-faced little
lad not even that old now 29 yeah you're
a young fella well and so what happened
is they kind of had their interpretation
from whatever the young turks said about
me
because when i had 50,000 subscribers it
was like their day job to go after me
and now when I've had Alex Jones and
we've been doing proactive parodies of
The Young Turks callin amount Aston and
debate they will trash talk every
conservative not named steven crowder
it's like I'm Voldemort my name won't be
spoken when I had 50,000 subscribers
they would talk about me all the time
and they
you know a million or two million now
that's changed and people are able to
come here directly I feel lonely that
you're not sorry well give me your
lighter the matches are getting annoying
yeah thank you so you know I'd like to
think but you know there's also the real
possibility that people just don't like
me because I'm kind of a dick well you
can be a dick sometimes but you're a
funny dick like you do some funny [ __ ]
like one of the things he did that was
really funny was uh well what was that
feminist rally thing that you went to he
drives like the recent one where the
[ __ ] yeah and I actually interviewed
Wendy Davis I don't think you're
supposed to say [ __ ] bro yeah I don't
really that's why people don't like me
sometimes but I think now you're seeing
more people say that they don't care I
think it's funny when they start making
words taboo I really do like people said
[ __ ] forever and then all sudden it's
like disparaging okay I even noticed in
the new bill bird special he said like
Oh what are you gonna do you'll [ __ ]
marry you know I was like he would have
said [ __ ] four years ago cuz he did in
his special and used the word marry
talking about like a [ __ ] isn't like
that's not it that's not a word we ever
heard him used before Oh bill uses that
word yeah that's a Boston word yeah you
[ __ ] Mary yeah yeah people call guys
Mary's well he's probably he's trying to
be a little bit more politically correct
you know what I do I use the word but I
do it in character I didn't say Nigel
said it that was not me I had this joke
about tigers in Texas I don't know if
you know my my this is a true story from
my last Netflix special there are more
tigers in captivity in Texas than there
are in all of the wild of the world in
private collections in people's
backyards there are more Tigers in Texas
than the rest of the [ __ ] planet
Earth
that is a fact that is a real step
because they can have them just a bunch
of dentists who carry them back just
dude I know people that you know people
that have Tigers I know people in Texas
whose friends have Tigers they just you
can have a type are you aware by the way
what's the biggest cat it you probably
know this but the biggest predatory cat
you know well ligers but it's not
they're not viable I can't breathe well
I thought the lion at first during tiger
weighed so much bigger I learned Jack in
the Roman Roman times in the Coliseum
this is what
can't entirely corroborate us I will say
it's been corroborated when you do so
the lions and they said the Lions have
to be on three points and can paw
whereas the Siberian tigers would
leverage back and pounce yeah said it
wasn't even close not to mention that
the Tigers are way bigger but they were
able to just go back on their two legs
whereas the lion has to have three
points of contact which is like a dog
even the paw yeah yeah so when I saw it
I was like well that's that's something
that's pretty incredible because you see
a lion I mean you know your dice are the
ghost in the darkness that's pretty
scary well it's not even close the
mountain lion will [ __ ] you up dude like
just a small mountain lion at eighty
pound mount line yeah [ __ ] you up but a
Siberian tiger will [ __ ] you up in ways
you couldn't possibly imagine
well I have a dog Hopper dog of
argentino oh those are big dogs
well my Google Sketch - they're not
they're not trained him good but they're
sketchy
well he is he ran for president with
Dean Cain and he had like a few hundred
votes which I felt bad about cuz it was
a gag so who knows if that changed the
state of Michigan but by the way if it
starts going out you put two fingers
over kind of create a slipstream and
suck it in and I'll give you probably
not now you probably need to relight it
it's not like a cigar it's not good to
talk and smoke a pipe it's meant to be
more contemplative mmm but Bertrand
Marcille used to smoke a pipe Nitti was
a trainee it was one of the things like
he wanted to fly and he would only fly
if he could smoke on the plane because
he was so addicted to tobacco that he
had to constantly smoke there is that's
how he would speak but it is it is very
relaxing because it's kind of like like
jiu-jitsu you set you've used the term
moving meditation mm-hmm when you're
sitting down there outside at the end of
the day if you don't focus on it it's
gonna go out it's not like a cigar it's
not like a cigarette so you have to sit
there and focus on the draw focus on the
exhale and all you're thinking about is
is the pipe so it really is kind of a
contemplative art no you're getting
[ __ ] up on tobacco why are you lying
man you're lying to people what were you
talking about before that Tigers in
Texas there's more taller than me dude
you're going all over the place run a
youtube search on dog argentino mountain
lions you will see dog oh argentinos
Messing
actual mountain lions yeah you know why
cuz the mount line once get away it's
probably true the mountain lion does
want to fight to the death the mountain
lion is a predatory animal predatory
animals don't necessarily fight to the
death it's one of the reasons why dogs
are so [ __ ] dangerous because dogs
are bred to not feel pain
not recognizing that's one of things
that about pit bulls they're not the
biggest strongest dogs yeah but they're
bred to ignore pain and that that that
drive to attack and ignore pain makes
them very problematic right you just
used the word problematic let's let's
ban that word smoking a pipe but yeah
they are that's what they're bred for
they're actually really people oriented
because they're bred to be protective of
people and hunt with people so they're
not bred to fight dogs right so a lot of
actually people there was that's what we
got Roe hopper he's a rescue out in in
Michigan a lot of guys in the inner
cities bought them thing and this is
like a bigger pit bull they're gonna be
great dog fighters they were horrible
and they just got abandoned so there's
all kinds of dogs out there in Western
Michigan I know if there still are I'm
wild dog goes well just our dog haha
look that looks very much like our done
good cute fella they're so big such a
big dog well ours is a little bit of a
runt
he's about 90 pounds because he we found
him with a broken leg roaming the
streets alopecia a Lyme disease well you
rescued him right off the street well no
he was rescued in to a lady who
specialized in dago's and then we took
him from her and he's the most people
oriented dog we've ever seen I mean to
the point where he'll actually the
biggest problem you have is if you stop
petting him and you don't know him he'll
growl for you to keep petting him so
kids are and they're terrified huh well
that seems like a Dicky dog yeah a
little bit I have a dog called a Regency
Mastiff oh yeah those are no joke yeah
it's a Neapolitan that's bred with a
pitbull so they're about 140 pounds to
do with the calf this is great my kids
ride him like literally ride him they
get on top of him and he'll just watch
it again PETA on you for that now they
shouldn't be riding he's older now poor
poor fella
he's like 11 he's got some hip problems
he's an walks with a limp well um thank
you very Mak you know part of your
audience doesn't like it but dude it
stands now who don't be a defensive
don't say that have you noticed a change
kind of a new sort of Trump well
culturally I think there's there
I know this is sound sounds like a
broken record but counterculture why's
he have a lot of people who were afraid
to even speak up even from the last time
I was on the show where they've been
called racist sexist homophobic
transphobic is the new thing or anyone's
going to know it alright fine let's go
with that I think if you were to hold
the election today Donald Trump would
win in a landslide wouldn't even be
close just music yeah that's because of
how bad the behavior has been from the
left all the rest of America
I had that my uber driver coming here
and she believed every liar name she was
a Latino woman why ever talk to drivers
about politics oh it always seems to end
in a TMZ explain we have a 4.2 rating so
I'm right at the threshold of losing my
uber privileges are you serious yeah so
like you get a rating as a customer yeah
you get a rating as a customer what's a
good rating of 10 you have a 4.2 no no
it's 5 it's out of five oh that's not
that bad no it's not that bad well if
you go to the floor you're out no yeah
you're out so you go like someone could
find you right now uber drivers could be
like unite yeah I'm blackballed you they
could well my friend I can't say his
name because it's illegal actually had
his concealed carry with him in an uber
and he forgot his magazine and that
person rated him like a 1 so it took one
bad rating to drop his score because he
had to call him say hey I think I forgot
something in the back of your car what
is it like a magazine he's like oh like
a People magazine he's like no just look
and the guy was just in the phone with
him saying what did you do in my car and
he just said I was going to the range he
wasn't he carries a gun on him
everywhere everywhere he goes but um
this lady Hoover la she decided to start
talking about it talking about the
women's March and stuff so I just it's
hard for me to say nothing but we ended
up on very good terms mister is a
different story this is not the message
not the magazine story and she talks
right now speed or anything do drugs
you're very quick that's going quick
well into the show I had that some nitro
coffee and I came from coffee bean Tea
Leaf right or you had that is 270
milligrams caffeine so I probably got
about five six hundred milligrams yeah
that's that's like two grande Starbucks
coffees seriously I think there's a
garden in the middle of that go nineties
200 yeah its closing closing in on two
Grande's um but she said she's like well
Donald Trump called all Mexicans rapists
said no she was Donald Trump is gonna
ruin gay rights so what I do
what what cuz it's because it's just in
my nature and as it won't why she was
because Donald Trump removed the gay
rights thing on the website I said what
about the fact that all presidents they
remove everything from the previous
administration and they put up new a
whole new whitehouse.gov website and
these people they buy in LA they're in
such an insular bubble I don't think
they realize there's a whole bunch of
people who voted for Donald Trump and I
wasn't a fan of him in the primaries but
they didn't vote from because they're
racist they didn't vote from because I
don't want Caitlyn Jenner to take a dump
at Trump Towers they didn't vote for him
because they hate brown people they
voted for him because they're tired of
being called all those things and that's
why I think you see a lot of these young
people who just kind of want to be
instigators and provocateurs but at the
same time they're appreciating more
traditionalism and some of the values
their parents try to instill in them
because that's kind of more rebellious
and going along with the entertainment
industry well there's always a sort of
longing for nostalgia that people
exhibit there's always like back in the
good old days like back in the good old
days is [ __ ] because the good old
days you died of syphilis the good old
days people got [ __ ] plague from rats
right there was no good old days this is
the good old days right now so there's
always that right there's always this
longing for nostalgia but I think I
think you're right with some people but
for sure there's some people that are
racist they're voted for Donald Trump
just because some people are racist sure
yeah of course but to try and paint I
mean you look at the numbers a huge
percentage of people who voted for
Barack Obama had to a voted for Donald
Trump particularly in Michigan and
Pennsylvania there just aren't the
numbers there well don't you think that
they probably voted for him a lot of it
is for economic reasons because they
thought that he's gonna loosen up some
regulations encourage industry I think
it's the opposite a lot of the Union
voters they thought Hillary Clinton was
in the pocket of Goldman Sachs right and
they thought Donald Trump was his sort
of economic protectionism is going to
bring jobs back to the Midwest which
that's one like encourage industry
that's monitoring I disagree with the
idea of for example I've been in
Michigan the unions have a stranglehold
I would rather GM be able to move to
Texas or anywhere they want to be
competitive in the car market but I
can't even get to that because as soon
as we don't hold on Donald Trump made a
mistake here I disagree with him because
then there's a women's March where
they're lighting hair on fire and
calling him literally Hitler was
lighting hair on fire what do you mean
at the woman's Marsh girl got her hair
lit on fire a girl yeah by some with one
of those [ __ ]
see you know what man the thing about
that stuff is it's always one [ __ ]
person or a couple people out of
hundreds of thousands that are acting in
that mob mentality in a violent [ __ ]
incorrect oh come on man there's not
that many people that do violent [ __ ] at
those women's marches why there was no
arrests no every well there were no
arrests the Lansing protests either were
they cut down a tent with box cutters
there were little Lansing protests when
I went right to work that was a big
thing where I was there but even the
inauguration Pro that was that the one
you got punched yeah I did get punched
yeah that wasn't so much hilarious that
I couldn't punch well I know but when
you're not expecting why throw a punch
when you don't know how to punch like
don't think about everywhere left us
gather though whether it's Woodstock
back then Woodstock 99 Woodstock by Wall
Street violent yes how do you know you
there there are reports of rape that's
rapes that occurred with a rape rapes or
were they like I think back then they
were rapists
back then Lena Dunham wasn't you know
shoving fast-food napkins and her
sister's couch claiming she was raped
because she saw the condom in a potted
plant
so what Lena Dunham she claims she was
raped because she saw the condom on a
plant after she was drunk on muscle
relaxers I feel like we always come back
to Lena Dunham yeah I didn't know about
that story I knew that there was some
sort of a gross interaction with her
younger sister yeah she was reaching in
her in her in her in her vagina but the
point is anywhere leftist gather there
is always violence there's a giant
exaggeration I mean when the woman's
born to nail a rat you know violence
there was no arrest there was no not a
second you say there was no violence but
people said there was no violence at all
these other marches right with renze
again it's like isolated incidents not
when you have to look at a trend right
I'm not saying everyone okay you've got
a million people in LA a million people
mark right it's 970,000 peep okay but
you have way more than that with the Tea
Party which was accused of being racist
not one minute there's never way more
than that oh yeah you never had a march
in LA that had more people than 907
across the country part the first people
yeah yeah more people across the country
a party that's there's no way yeah hold
on a second not a model the day of March
when there were hundreds of thousands of
people all over the country marching
together in one day yeah there was never
a movement like that for the Tea Party
yes it was a day with the Tea Party the
one day the one day at a hundred
thousand in Washington DC
okay that's less than was in LA right
for the women's brought across the
country because there were so many like
in Dallas there were four or five
different ones across Dallas you're the
same in the same day come on yeah in the
same day no not is how many different
cities had a march like that for the Tea
Party yeah they were one hundreds of
cities hundreds of cities simultaneously
in one day and it was bigger than the
women's march certainly comparable well
not a single incident and they left the
place is cleaner than they found them
you look at Occupy Wall Street over five
hundred crimes including felonies you
look at the women's March let's
disregard the crime people up there with
[ __ ] hats bringing their two-year-old
with the most profane disgusting signs
you can imagine when leftist congregate
it's generally not a peaceful assembly
not in the same way as when people who
are right-wing congregate look at
Berkeley Jake Shields of vegan from
Berkeley is becoming a vegetarian sorry
vegetarian from Berkeley it's becoming
conservative because he just said this
was this was the rule not the exception
in Berkeley well I know Jake he's a
buddy mine and essentially he was saying
that these people that were doing what
they're claiming they're fighting
fascists he's like you're being a
fascist do you understand what a fascist
means right using violence to enforce
your ideology and you're tolerating no
deviations from that ideology that that
is being a fascist yeah this pipe smoke
it blows bro your own takes too much
effort but well we had him on the show
and he was saying like you know I just
it's changed where the left we need to
call this out and we need to we need to
take ownership over this and we need to
we need to squash it because it's coming
a real problem it's also a problem when
you say the left the left or the right
because it's not necessarily just the
left
it's these [ __ ] idiots that go to
these things and put masks on and want
to beat people up and mace women I saw
that girl with a make make Bitcoin great
again hat
she had a joke hat and someone hit her
over the head with a stick
yeah what that was holding up a sign and
then another guy Meister
you know face I mean and they think that
they can inauguration you had people
getting pulled out of cars getting
punched you know Occupy Wall Street you
get people putting
bloody rags on tents that they claimed
had AIDS I mean anywhere again just go
back through history in the last decade
it's very different and not saying all
left-right we're speaking you have to
speak in generalities to save time but
as a general rule if you look at the
right if you look at for example the Tea
Party you look at the movement people
who were complaining about the stimulus
package you look at people with economic
problems with Barack Obama they didn't
try it they didn't beat people up in
record numbers there was not a single
trashcan lid on fire thrown through a
window that seems to be a common
occurrence at these leftist protests
well it is now it is now it certainly is
now because I think Howard well it's
also these people feel like what Donald
Trump represents is the worst possible
scenario for the right they feel like he
represents this like really arrogant
businessman who promotes rape culture
and grabbing [ __ ] and you know that's
how that's how they're looking at it so
like it's time to act like there's some
woman who was on Fox News the other
who's the one that dude Tucker Tucker
Carlson yeah
is he a Fox News guy used to be CNN on
crossfire right and he had some woman on
and she was talking a little Asian yeah
yeah and she's a [ __ ] schoolteacher
she's talking about beating people up
and I was like this is crazy like she's
talking about she called my low
gianopolous who was a gay Jew by the way
she called him homophobic and prefers
prefers black men yeah I mean but how do
you call a gay guy homophobic just when
everyone's a Nazi now I mean I was not
for Trump in the primary so I get called
a [ __ ] right I was like well listen he's
the most liberal Republican ever people
don't want to talk he's the only
Democrat most of his life he's the only
president to ever take office being Pro
gay marriage when he was sworn in Barack
Obama can't even claim that it was the
first person that's something that
people need to recognize about Hillary
Clinton she was anti gay marriage as
recently as 2013 she was she was
speaking in 2013 and she said I believe
that marriage is a bond between a man
and a woman in 2013 and she was making
arguments too it wasn't like she was put
on the spot and well I think she was out
there arguing against same-sex marriage
so um you know my point here is they're
out of power and so they declare
everyone or not see you know they
declare me and not see they'll declare
Milo a Nazi and so if you say hey there
it's okay to punch Nazis in the face if
Hitler walked in here
you'd probably have a tussle with Adolf
Hitler but it's acceptable if you make
me or even you or Milo equivalent to
Hitler and that's what they're doing now
and that's the point that I'm making is
I think because they behaved so poorly
more Americans would would vote screw
you with the lever and vote for Donald
Trump now than they did end of memory
that's highly speculative
it is highly strict crowd hence the pipe
we can speculate and Paul Riley
speculative not sure if I buy it might
maybe let me think people are also
freaking out they're freaking out about
his appointment of a golden Sachs
executive they're freaking out over
what's happening with that Flynn fellow
who was forced to resign because he was
coordinating with Russia and you know
talking about removing sanctions before
they got into office and all that stuff
well that was a screw-up but you know
I'm not here to defend Donald you'll
always screw up we call it treason if I
he's a whole new man
it is delicious though isn't it it's
good it really is guys [ __ ] right now oh
really
he hit some marijuana after this
probably like takes you to the next
level but yeah then gets you high as
[ __ ] man that's pretty low in nicotine
Oh an aromatic like that yeah but I'm a
rookie all right you know I don't smoke
any smoke a cigar yeah but it's pretty
occasional like maybe once a month I'll
puff a cigar yeah well yeah there you go
you can keep that one no it's already
broken in yeah keep this pipe yeah
because there's a real break on process
with a pipe it's actually you know you
have to smoke it really slow when you
first get it because the Breyer expands
so I know Pierre [ __ ] different
voice fuel [ __ ] and [ __ ] them I
don't know if that's a word transom you
let me present this okay you take
someone learning Sanders son of a [ __ ]
well you're 20 relax drink tea drink I
drink you drink wait this man some
whiskey let's get some whiskey up in
here we need to do it cast is very we
need drink drink real booze now what do
you wanna talk to Sam I just want to
relax a little okay you don't want you
to be a human and one of these talking
points these aren't talking we've fired
up to [ __ ] defend the right and
promote your agenda well just cuz I know
you said people like they think you're
an [ __ ] because your right-wing
care what they think people think I'm a
[ __ ] meathead well I'm right there
are I am in a way very meathead you're
strong no well I'm [ __ ] I eat meat
I'm a cage fighting commentator I look
like a meathead there's a lot of
meathead qualities that I possess
although I'm the kind of person you are
open-minded and more probably more left
than I am right if you looked at a giant
spectrum I don't think so no no not
anymore I just think it's such a narrow
path on the Left there's so unaccepting
of people that's why you've seen all
this blonde very accepting in that way I
mean I'm very accepting even of
ridiculous ideas I want you to talk
about them you know why I just think one
of the real problems that I have right
now with all these protesters and all
these people that are going crazy and
calling everybody Nazis is you're
stifling communication yeah and you're
stifling the market place of Freddy's I
don't on real booze bro get out get out
some whiskey what's that good even
better make it hurt
bring out some whiskey bring out that
Alex Jones whiskey the stuff that makes
you talk about interdimensional child
molesters actually stop talking about
pizza gate remember there was a big
conscious oh you didn't when I had him
on here oh really oh yeah Eddie was
probably instigating oh yeah Eddie was
out of his [ __ ] mind drunk he doesn't
know what he did oh my god I don't here
we go it may not be true but what do you
think about what Breitbart was saying
like way back in 2011 about Podesta that
Podesta like shields pedophiles and who
come on don't be a [ __ ] marketing I
think he gave it to me for free [ __ ] off
gentlemen Jack Jack Daniels dead yeah I
know I enjoy Jack King don't you never
had Gentleman Jack have now well because
you asked me about it and the first
thing where my antenna went up with
pizza gate as I said Jane James Oliphant
this means I love kids in French and I
know where they're trying to get it from
it's Jim Lee's off huh that's not James
elefantes hmm so right away when it's
the print the first
I miss that I read is a lie I'm going
alright well there was a bunch of weird
ones but there was some stuff that was
like really odd like the pizza place
that had that symbol that is the
International [ __ ] symbol for
pedophilia and child molesting and
Beyonce's in the Illuminati but no this
is a symbol that the FBI admits that
they use in these secret organizations
when they capture pedophiles which they
do all the time yeah they use that
symbol I mean they agree upon that
symbol it says there's a lot of
weirdness to it and here's the thing it
could be this is my take on it and I
don't have a side and I'm not I'm not
claiming that I have any knowledge but
they're absolutely our pedophile rings
they exist they've caught them before
they busted him before
like Jerry Sandusky's kid just got
busted I know yesterday that was the
beauty of Michael Jackson the guy was so
clever about it think about it he
screwed every kid in Hollywood except
Macaulay Culkin so he's that canary in
the coal mine Macaulay Culkin's no no I
got a Neverland Ranch he never touched
me that's what I was like - the other
kids are coming back they still swear up
no I would say it's like if you went if
you went to a bachelor party and
everybody got their dick sucked and your
wife said hey what the [ __ ] Bobby says
he got his dick sucked not me I don't
know I mean maybe she just didn't like
me yeah but Macaulay Culkin has no
reason to say that now yes he does
really yeah nobody wants to know that
you got molested by Michael Jackson
you'll never get a girlfriend again we
get one hell of a book deal come on you
should be about to go down on you and
she'll think oh my god Michael Jackson
suck this dick oh right don't you think
you'll get one of a book deal well you
know Andrew Breitbart actually not
Breitbart the the trademark Andrew
bright part the the name is I mean he
was actually I got my start and he wrote
about that you know Neverland Ranch his
photographer was a pornographer who
specialized in European actors who
looked underage and so once he talked
about this the guy was fired from
Neverland Ranch I think it was six
months later he was back so my point was
like the pizza except is there are
things that are provable like that which
people can go search Andrew Breitbart
and find that story and because people
are cocked and loaded to hate someone
from the right online cocked well you
really do go do a different voice was
with net nasty words that was my beavis
and butthead voice because of that I'd
rather dwell on stories that we know we
can prove or calm
Terry because it's really easy to go oh
router was wrong with pizza gate or
whatever it is so we just there's so
much there Neil that's right folks
that's my issue with Alex Jones yeah
Alex Jones goes super deep and I did not
know before I had him that he was a
Sandy Hook denier and I saw that and
it's pretty rough he'd hurt my soul it
really did yeah he's um he's been very
his son as a fan he's been really really
good to me and coming on the show he's
done the Young Turks sketches with us
I think he's doing less of the
conspiracy stuff now it's it's less now
get him get him drunk get him drunk and
watch it come out well doesn't surprise
me alex has been my friend for a long
time he's yeah 84% crazy but he's he's
he's like it's one of those things where
if you chase death there's enough
corruption and enough crazy [ __ ] in the
world that if you chase it down you're
gonna find it right it's there but you
got to be careful what you call
corruption and what you call
conspiracies right is there a a [ __ ] ton
of them that he's missing the mark like
the Sandy Hook thing I mean that that
the Sandy Hook thing is so [ __ ] there
was a great article that was written
about a guy who was a conspiracy
theorist until his kid was killed at
Sandy Hook right and then realized like
holy [ __ ] like these people are telling
me that my kid didn't die when I
realized how dangerous this whole
thinking that the government sprang [ __ ]
in the sky from mind control and the CIA
is a mind control organization right
I've been told that I'm in the [ __ ]
CIA oh yeah they're people think I'm in
the Illuminati hmm how do we get in I
think two days do you think you could
get in or we are you young and you too
old are you young rather I have no idea
I think you just need to have the
all-seeing eye in one of your music
videos and you're in like flint that is
it you just gotta go like this like JC I
think there's easy doing diamonds you
say like diamonds or is he like doing a
little bit well I didn't realize diamond
is also like a black term for a lady's
nether regions really I found that in
risque songs smell yo dick you hear that
song yes yes yeah my smell
I was welding I wasn't clown like that
he says diamond like that now was this
feeling heard I'm like that like that
I've heard of white people who were out
of touch with black culture that's man
was ridiculous welcome welcome to me I
didn't know I have to tune to Jamie coz
Jamie's on black Twitter everyday Jamie
keeps he said totally but I was down a
vine must have been rough for you
Jamie's got TweetDeck and he sets up one
hashtag black Twitter and it's just all
blacked such as buzz it's all just black
Twitter references and he tells me that
like people steal from black Twitter and
they make jokes on late-night TV cos
yeah subculture yeah black Twitter they
say funny [ __ ] and then people steal it
is that true Jamie is that what you said
I heard that's the rumor that is what he
heard I've heard that too
when did women it's being a witch like
black is a subculture right we talk
about minority groups I think you need
another drink women more whiskey I'll
finish that no come on doesn't work on
me yet see you weren't any Illuminati
you're treating my man like that see
time is a stripper this whole thing up
dude see you're spreading disinformation
that's not how a [ __ ] get her ice wall
up
that's just lazy song let's get her i
swell up yes he's promoting violence
against women because she'll just smell
his dick she beats the hell out of her
but that's not my fault
song they didn't even introduce the
character Diamond beforehand how am I
supposed to know we can't know that's
not a racism thing that's a bad song
okay if he said I ain't even feel in
Mercedes like that would you assume okay
Mercedes is probably a stripper lapses
to the main stage probably but I know I
didn't read the lyrics so I didn't see a
capital on Diamond I can't know this hmm
I was trying to be understanding of
another culture and it backfired I'm
gonna be then yeah why doesn't he just
wash his dick automatic hand cleaner
doesn't he have hand sanitizer he keeps
in his [ __ ] Benz just spray thieves
essential oil at your dick bro dirty
[ __ ] coming home with a dirty dick
Jesus that's like worse than adultery on
your wife dirty start that's not as why
for sure first of all that can be not
married this is not a marriage we're
talking about this nothing oh look at
this more booze bring it out both bring
them both out this guy needs to get
drunk talks too much [ __ ] you want to
talk about everything okay life
generally okay let's say this generally
I've never been as mad as I was watching
that Holly Holm fight why because of the
here's what I think I think if you hit
someone after the bell and it's really
clear it should be an immediate point
deduction and they should be given time
to recover more than a minute
that's just an opinion why you twice I
agree with you but here's why I disagree
with you I'm even more extreme I think
that hitting someone after the bell is
grounds for a disqualification yeah
because you know you know you know you
know BAM you know go down your whole
mindset changes you're not expecting it
she definitely heard the Bell the guy
was stepping in she threw the shots it's
grounds for disqualification you know I
fought you know it's been a long time
but I did and I heard bells and I didn't
hit anybody afterwards you know what the
[ __ ] it is you know what it is well if
you do the point deduction Holly wins
that fight or a draw for sure Jemaine
Duran to me is [ __ ] awesome she's an
awesome fighter I mean she's a 46 and Oh
10 time world Muay Thai champion and for
that to happen with her it upsets me in
in two ways one it upsets me because
Holly got fouled and two it upsets me
because she's a great fighter right for
her to do something like that I was like
why did you do that don't do that
yeah and she rocked Holly the problem is
when you rock someone who knows how much
that affects them for the rest of the
fight right Holly is so badass
she not only came back from that she
came back from that one up head kicking
Germain wrapping her and then rocking
her little hook that we first yeah yeah
was it a straight left I thought was
like a hook with gnarly rocked her yeah
straight limbs a straight left that she
was coming in was just really short then
perfect shot
yeah well she's incredible she's so
badass and that question mark kick did
she hit it with over the top of the
shoulder drops down and hits her in the
head isn't it funny though that she
doesn't she doesn't fight like a boxer
in the Octagon at all she fights much
more like an American kickboxer
well because she was also an American
kickboxer and she's also trained by Mike
Winkeljohn who like one of the best
American kick boxers from his era yeah
he was world-class in his time he's
really good when he fought he fought Ric
Rufus right he fought some really good
guys he's a great striking coach man
very similar to him you know when I'm in
Dallas guy Mezger a very similar style
to that kind of standard yeah not as
much head movement yeah I met scores of
a good friend of mine I love that guy
he's really just an awesome guy won't
get into personal stories but he's been
he's done I know there's some really
nice things for people and he's a really
he's the exact example of when people
say fighters are meatheads you just a
really kind-hearted guy well he's
definitely not a meathead
I'm more of a meathead than him for sure
he's uh he's not just a kind-hearted guy
he's very intelligent soft-spoken
you never hear guy Metzger yelling at
people and he's he's also you know he's
I worked really hard to mitigate some of
his brain trauma and been really open
about it you know I think is very very
very important because it's like this
silent thing that guys don't want to
talk about the issues that they're
dealing with from fighting yeah well um
he also did you hear the story about
when he got into the fight in a parking
lot was like a bunch of guys who jumped
him yeah well how long just one that
long ago no you're probably thinking the
one where the guy had a knife and
actually stabbed him in the yes cuz he
got in between an altercation between
him you just don't do that stay home no
this was something maybe he may not want
me to tell the story but it was in a
parking lot something happened I don't
know how it started but what happened
was there were three or four guys and
all he did was he grabbed one guy just
got him to the ground somehow and put
him in a chokehold and he told his
friend he said if you come forward I'm
gonna choke your friend out and they
just got back into the rav4 closed the
doors he let the guy go they were gone
that's a really nice person mostly was
well he also he's a striker he could
have really hurt him yeah that's kind of
the beauty of grappling you can hurt
them or not as much as you want to right
my master is a very high level striker I
mean he's not known as a grappler so
that's well he's a grappler too he
choked out Tito Ortiz and there's one of
his first ufc's he just won worlds at
brown in the senior division did you
really yeah McGee that's amazing yeah
he's still competing and doing that
stuff that's pretty awesome guys that's
a nice thing for people that don't want
to strike anymore I know babalu Sobral
he's been doing a lot of grappling
competitions yeah if you know guys that
just have like taken a lot of head
trauma a lot of crazy fights long
careers you know they still like to
compete they can do that and you know
and babalu has I think it's Baba lose
iron gym I think that's what he calls it
and he's got a really nice high level
gym down in Orange County and you know
that's an explanation every time parents
taking their kids for lessons they walk
in and see babalu high but they have to
do that that kind of all right let me
his neck yeah yeah parents are gonna be
a little apprehensive great guy he's a
great guy and he's a real pioneer babalu
was in the early early days of fighting
you see there's a fight with him and
Brad colder it's one of the [ __ ]
scariest knockouts ever cuz its back
when you can soccer kick on the ground
yeah and he dropped Brad koltes babalu
was one of the first Brazilian wrestlers
mm-hmm which a lot of people don't know
I mean he was a black belt in Brazilian
jiu-jitsu and very good striker and all
those things but yeah he also was on the
Brazilian national wrestling team back
in the day yeah and so Brad Kohler who
was like this really beefed up [ __ ]
just Jack dude could couldn't touch him
on the feet and bablu eventually got him
tired out and when he dropped him got
him down to the ground [ __ ] soccer
kicked him into a Bolivian it was just
those days when you can when you could
soccer kick someone who was already
tired and down yes sir those are dark
play to put into context the Brazilian
national wrestling team
they'd be like ventures to Oklahoma
State wrestlers it's just not even the
same level maybe but a high level
wrestlers a high level road yeah it is
but it's like Sara McMann you know she
was silver at the Olympics never when
people said she was gonna beat Ronda
with the wrestling like my aunts like in
the talent pool and women's wrestling is
nowhere near where it is a judo at that
point you just have women in Japan and
judo who are thermals Kayla Harrison to
moon following her she was actually one
of the first guests on her show she just
a monster yeah there's no one in female
wrestling no one who would even come
close to her level of experience the
same can be said about Brazilian
jiu-jitsu
you know Brazilian jiu-jitsu which isn't
in the Olympics yet but really should be
is there's some phenomenal like you've
seen McKenzie Dern you've seen her
compete in MMA
I haven't well yeah she has what's the
most badass choke outs that I've ever
seen in my life she started with an
omoplata work
this girl's back she's got this move
that she does well she gets a girl in
Roma Plata and she rolls over onto her
back and chokes this chick out
apparently she hits this move all the
time
well they teach something similar to
that at marcelo garcia school in new
york where if ever someone's turtling
you wedge your knee into their ribs and
their hip crease and you kind of get
around it not quite an omoplata but
you're bringing your other leg around
their front and you're wrapping and
you're blocking if let's say coming in
from your right side you blocked their
left arm which is something we actually
would learn in judo quite a bit a really
basic back so you've lat you broke
blockage by taking and under so you're
grabbing in and you're gonna have and
wrist control around so you're not
putting a hook in and when you control
this the way they taught it to me like
if you watch marcelo garcia they'll just
go for the choke straight from there
they don't even need to get their hooks
in right and you know then you have
Clark Gracie you does the omoplata roll
to the lapel choke I mean it really is
omoplata is I don't think there's been a
submission from that in a long time but
well there's only ever in the UFC
history then Saunders
this is McKenzie Dern watch how she does
this is also is that she's hot as [ __ ]
and so she she gets the she gets the
omoplata to the girl tries to roll now
watch how she handles this when she gets
her from this position no no no you got
to go back it's just a highlight video
so she doesn't she doesn't need the hook
no so what she does is she rolls and
yeah you don't see it from that position
well that's a lot like a noogie version
of Clark Gracie's omoplata lapel tree
let me see if they show it here what she
does is she gets up and when she gets up
on her hip she the girl rolls and then
watch how she scrambles now she takes
her right um they don't show it she
takes her right arm and she rolls
underneath the girl yeah anyway you know
her dad is megaton Diaz who's world
famous ya know very very respected
Brazilian jiu-jitsu blackbelt but
there's one of the coolest things about
jiu-jitsu is it's like almost like
sentences and languages there's so many
different ways you can go with things
yeah there's so many different
possibilities it's just it's almost
never-ending well there's a guy like my
dad you know it's in his 50s and hasn't
lost a point let alone around competing
up to purple belt and he competes
against guys who were 40 and openweight
cuz there's no one his age and you know
played hockey U of M high high level
athlete and
he's not super flexible he's not gonna
do a guard game he got really good at
takedowns really good at trips really
good at guard passing and side control a
few chokes you know paper cutter chew
things like that and he's he's diverse
enough where he can protect himself in
areas but that's one thing too you know
when I was helping coach him for his
first tournament listen in training you
want to work these positions you know
you want to work your guard you want to
Warcraft guard but there's nothing that
says in the competition you can't stuff
the head get up and just come up on top
and when you realize that when he
competes it's just getting out getting
on top and if he gets on top he's gonna
pass you know what his level at a purple
belt level the problem with that
strategy is it only works with someone
who's weaker than you like as soon as
you find someone who's better at that
game than you you have to have other
options well if he's not good off of his
back
someone's eventually gonna put him eyes
but he's pretty good in his back that's
good but in a tournament the point is
there's no unwritten agreement where
we're working passing no I mean so he
can try his you know scissor sweep which
is a big thing for him as a strong guy
and if it doesn't work he can do a
technical standout and come up well
house and Gracie has the best
description of jiu-jitsu
he said you do this then I do that then
you do this then I do that forever yeah
I love that because it's like once if
you tried you just so you go yeah that
is what it is until someone taps like
you like Hicks and Gracie's always been
famous for saying about other other
athletes other competitors that if they
can't keep the rhythm there will lose my
really amazing meaning not like George
same here but like meaning that he keeps
keeps attacking and you keep defending
and keep attacking eventually you're
gonna slip up right he's gonna get a
dominant position sure and then once
from there I'm not saying he's
world-class I'm just saying he's able to
learn a game I know you want to brag
about your dad thank you gentlemen Jack
I guess something oh no that's normal
Jack this is regular Jack hmm yeah what
is this tough call this is a natural
[ __ ] that's how you sell it if they were
sponsored they were natural sponsor you
be getting phone calls yes Sinatra [ __ ]
and our PR representatives have a
problem with that well then they
wouldn't be a sponsor anymore
nobody cares anymore man this people
have to realize is the age
[ __ ] you can say it you know it's
actually a great whiskey that has world
is Wild Turkey one-on-one
that stuff's disgusting no no no no no
we have some you want some no I'm good
[ __ ] but while turkey 101 is a
fantastic drink it really is it's like
Jim Beam advertises aged for years
well while turkey 101 is eight years off
the bat why is it better to be old why
is it better for whiskey to be aged look
what we've been saving this tastes like
[ __ ] just be honest it always like [ __ ]
no oh if the Rye you want it younger
with a bourbon you want that you want
more of that char kind of flavor in
there it's a good it's a good whiskey
the best whiskey can't [ __ ] with
kool-aid kool-aid tastes better than the
best whiskey kool-aid what are you doing
with Sinatra [ __ ] I like the pain I like
feeling I like the suffering I like the
suffering that comes with Jack Daniels
that's what I like real like when you
shoot that shot down ego you you know
exactly what you just did you're not
playing any stupid you know any poison
like I'm here to enlighten myself I'm
here just spread love and karma I know
what people do what with horchata what's
not with horchata is a Mexican drink I'm
thinking rum chata yeah rum chata so
chad has some [ __ ] we get with you get
tacos in an authentic joint
I was thinking rum chata I miss what's
rum cha don't even know what that is
they sell it's like horchata but
alcoholic and they saw a white bottle
and it's already pre-made and it's just
got the spices and whatever the dairy
filler is it's like a good thing to make
terrible decisions on well not gay Jared
loves it so it fits in perfectly well he
loves wrong cohost not give do so [ __ ]
is not gay Jared he's my producer on my
show um so you after this election I'm
where where do you line up now where are
you because beforehand you were kind of
I mean you saw the black lives matter
thing and he talked about I'm more
libertarian than anything so did you but
I'm Gary Johnson I did but only because
he did my podcast
oh really yeah I'm like you do my
podcast I'll vote for you for president
its deal's a deal
pretty smart pot and doing your podcast
she should have got him high right no we
talked pretty sensibly I liked Gary as
human and then I think he's good guy and
I think that um the Aleppo thing sunk
that [ __ ] boat like a goddamn torpedo
when he didn't know what a left
like okay here's the thing plays good
pool most people don't know about Aleppo
when that happened every there was a
spike in Google searches for Aleppo I
know he doesn't know what Aleppo is no I
didn't know I didn't know about Aleppo I
knew that Syria was in a terrible
terrible situation and I knew the Syrian
refugees that are flings I knew the
bombings I knew I didn't know the name
of the city the problem is you know he
got caught not knowing the name of the
city and he should have known the name
of the city like if you ask me you know
you know how do you think Matt Hume
handles mighty Mouse's career I'd be
like who Fox man Hume if I said that I
shouldn't be doing mmm commentator you
ever again but yeah I'm an Eman I'm a
mixed martial arts commentator that is
part of my job if you're running for
president it's part of your job though
the name of the city you know so the
worst when you try to cover it up like
Africa's what is Aleppo yes yes got it
got it he's at twice buying some time
she said you know what I don't really
know but I'm a libertarian so it
wouldn't even be in Aleppo so what does
it matter
yeah but see I don't buy that either man
once you've entangled yourself in the
world of politics foreign politics and
international politics the idea that
you're not gonna be there anymore well
we've found out what happens with that
in Iraq we found out what happens with
that in Libya you create a vacuum and
that vacuum is filled by terrible
terrible people well particularly when
you give them a timetable of when you're
gonna pull out yeah you know and
everyone on the right was saying won't
listen that's that's a mistake no no
this is gonna work well trust me but in
his defense what the [ __ ] else do you do
I mean do you stay there stay there and
and if you keep putting in there it's
not gonna light at least an hour
well afterward I'll show you how to get
it done really round we're already doing
it like a man my starter farkleberry
well you're gonna suffocate the flame
yeah modern technology well here is
something that I that I do think we've
seen afterwards again I wasn't a big
Trump supporter with that you want to go
back tone you did say we can but I think
just talk to jets I mean we talk
politics
let's talk Jack Daniels with Bernie
Sanders or whoever it is you can't line
up with the black lives matter you all
the time you can't line up with the
[ __ ] hat economics the women's March
all the time you can't line up with the
anti-free speech protestors
campus all the time he can't line up
with the people online who want to ban
voices of dissent all the time
he can't line up with we want to tax the
wealthy can you line up well the point
is people like Bernie or Hillary when
they do that until you realize hold on a
second there's a line and I've lined up
with everyone except for the rest of
America and you see that in Los Angeles
it's an insulated bubble people don't
realize you know what they're a lot of
keeps or New York whatever in the coding
cities won't you relax didn't you didn't
go to Colorado on point cuz you hated it
no I wanted to live I D I do not like
the population I do love the mountains
right I got a straight off the mountain
t-shirt on hoyt archery dot-com yeah
they could be in Washington no [ __ ]
bow hunter on that thing I think that
chickens yes right yeah I don't live in
Los Angeles right I live outside of Los
Angeles yeah I have several locations in
which I sleep I think I think that
there's there's a real problem with high
population areas and that problem is
there's two things one there's a
diffusion of responsibility there's too
many people you just feel like you don't
they don't value you don't value each
other because there's too many
there's everyone's there if you see an
accident you don't pull over to try to
help because there's a hundred thousand
people on the highway you just keep
going
yeah if you saw that same accident on a
single or a Lane Road in the country and
you know some cops worried you might
pull over and help you know you might
like New Yorkers care about each other I
got you walk past the hobo in the street
in New York for a lot of people they
just ignore it cuz they're so used to it
they did after 9/11 they did after 9/11
you know I went to New York after 9/11
we filmed a fear factor there and I'll
tell you man it was a beautiful thing
because there was there was a real
palpable like a tangible feeling of
community there that doesn't exist there
anymore no it's gone also the New York
that existed in 2001 is not the New York
that he is here in 2016 no you know I've
had some for like Judah Friedlander
who's a friend of mine is a stand-up
comic in series and he was telling me
he's like dude it's all bankers now he's
like there's no artists in New York
anymore they can't afford it he's like
if you you go to Brooklyn maybe well
he's like what in New York City the
rents are so [ __ ] expensive and
there's so much international money in
New York it's like I can tell you that's
flipped a little bit haven't when I
they're the lowest New York City I live
there when I was with Fox 4 well there
are two different stints one time
sleeping on couches and one time this
would have been 2011
maybe 2011 2012 and rent was cheaper in
old money Upper East Side than an East
Village or Lower East Side because
that's where all the hipsters and the
artists were so they all wanted to be
there now and the Upper East Side was
seen as not cool so I got a place that
was so inexpensive compared to if I
wanted to live down you know downtown so
that's kind of switched hmm
but no one know the artists want to live
with all the wasps this is always a
problem when too many people have too
much money and they're all congregated
in one area because then they're just
annoying
it's annoying they're all trying to buy
the same [ __ ] Carson
we're Bertrand Russell surf and pipes
and stomp on a little man
I am yeah I think you're right and I
think I think it also I mean there's
obviously this is where leftist tend to
Congress ideology in big cities right
they want you on public transportation
they want you to do that and they want
you riding bikes bro no they want you
well bikes public trans public transport
but certainly they want to limit what
kind of cards you can drive how far you
can drive them you mean any big city
they definitely wanna reduce
independence and there's a real I think
that's what it really is no they want to
reduce carbon emissions I don't want to
reduce independence no I think I think
it's both say that people want you on
buses and dependent on government just
like they want well the transit people
don't maybe some percentage of the
people do but if Tesla came out with
some car that you could drive across the
country on one charge you think people
would be suppressing that they would
welcome it a zero emissions car that you
give you total freedom no one's gonna
try to suppress that yeah the issue is
is wasn't anyone
I don't think so how and why they would
do is remove all the government
subsidies that make Tesla even remotely
competitor who is they this they [ __ ]
I'm not crazy I'm talking about the
United States government in the
subsidies that go into a Tesla right
Prius could still be losing Toyota on
everyone sold but you look at the
government subsidies the government
incentives to people don't want to buy
these cars oh that's not your Tesla yeah
but not a Prius that's not true either I
know a bunch of people bought praises my
premise is a Prius Brendan Schaub as a
Prius my buddies have pretty sure
he's got a [ __ ] Priya hasn't even fit
in a Prius in a Bentley well there you
can't barely [ __ ] big gorilla
he barely fits in a Prius I would say
those things handle like trash their
[ __ ] cars bill burr has a Prius how
about that in a Jaguar it's the white
guilt symbol in Los Angeles you can say
I got a Prius knowledge of the car
really say that but it's people that
don't want to spend a lot of money on
gas they borrow a lot of them bottom in
2008 here's well you don't want to spend
a lot of money on gas you would do the
cost savings estimation you would see
buying a used car any used car
especially a Ford Fiesta which would get
more mileage in a Prius anyway it's a
white guilt sim um no it doesn't it does
there are no Fiesta give more money or
American small cars it will get over 40
miles per gallon yeah but a priest gets
over 50 no pull it up Jamie its
[ __ ] right let me say let's say
it's an eighth mileage difference yeah
but that's not why you why you know what
an old car is gonna break down you want
a new car that's a reliable that gets
really really shouldn't even house with
a Prius way that's a [ __ ] no
seriously you don't that's gonna beat
are straight into your lungs if you
inhale I'm switching the weed you drive
me crazy so much better well back to the
well there you go alright so what's that
a Prius is Ford Fiesta
alright so 40 Highway 29 City Sun 40
Highway now pull up Priya's gonna have
way more in a city because there was a
battery work you because it's better son
of a [ __ ] you have a Prius your point
sucks no no that wasn't the point though
that was a that was a side no you're
trying to say that if you really wanted
to save money on gas you'd get a [ __ ]
shitty old Ford Fiesta and that's here's
the truth you're wrong no no no miles
per gallon you are incorrect if you look
at the actual price of a Prius versus
the best thing you can do for the
environment is buy an old beater car buy
an old Camaro this is poorly who said
that it's $24,000 it's cheap as [ __ ] for
a car
No you'd be better off buying an old
beater car recycle than buying a Prius
listen it's not even close big Euler
your heels
you don't see the other side you know
you like everybody helps them try to
giant non-recyclable batteries take your
heels your giant non recyclable non
recyclable for now but much like nuclear
waste it's making a comeback you know
that they can make diamonds batteries
out of diamonds with nuclear waste now
the last thousands of years yeah but why
do we want diamonds oh they make
batteries out of diamonds yeah the
nuclear waste nuclear diamond waste
batteries there's not thousands of years
nuclear energy that we could be using
but we can't be using because people
thought it was worse for the environment
wow it's we're using it whether people
thought it was worse or not the real
issue is like the old plants like
Fukushima that they have huge
difficulties with shutting down someone
told Mishima is not you know we're
talking about the other day that someone
had said that the radiation levels are
growing they're saying it's not growing
that the real issue is uh aerosol or
something that's the old global warming
but not aerosols what was the airborne
airborne radiation is an issue with
Fukushima that they're monitoring it
yeah it doesn't surprise me but you know
my point on that one is why wire left us
for example against the sharing economy
why would Bernie Sanders just abandon
the okay why is Bernie socialist Sanders
against the sharing economy you can't
you give him a nickname yeah you
son-of-a-bitch of socialist yourself
about European socialist why would they
be against the sharing one a thousand
dollars a year let's let's let's stand
around what you telling me no I want you
bring up your [ __ ] dog again what
about your dad is a Jitsu guy you said
you would not talk about politics
appendages say I don't want to talk no
Jamie
uber and airbnb shouldn't everyone be on
board with that why do you have people
like Bernie Sanders or Nancy Pelosi
banning them or poor Austin politicians
and constituents banning them from their
city if we're talking about sharing do
socialism yeah you can't do Ober in
Austin Bernie Sanders doesn't want to
over know why they're being why do you
think they're doing that do you think
they're doing that because they want
taxis to survive I think they're doing
it because just like people like to
throw out this big conspiracy about big
bankers and their own self-interest
which is true I think that people don't
want to acknowledge that the left is
beholden to giant cabby unions who are
punching people in the face in New York
because eibar removes their surcharge
and decides to ignore the Trump travel
ban I think they're against Airbnb
because they're beholden to for example
the culinary Union whom I usually meet
him in the side about the Trump travel
ban we're talking about that was people
were protesting an uber in New York City
right he went in and they were still
going to the airport the cabbies unions
in New York said we're not gonna go and
so people were punching over drivers
people getting furious about it saying
you're scabs you're coming in goober
actually removed their surcharge because
remember all the airport protests right
it was a quagmire I don't I don't oh
yeah
during the airport murder the Trump's
travel ban there are protests at all
these different airports right about
that yeah what does that have to do with
uber the point is in New York cabbies
unions went on strike they said against
the travel ban right
Oh supers going in weren't clear and
they're moving their surcharge well if
we're talking about the sharing economy
if we're talking about bringing in
refugees and resettling them against
people's will right because we want to
be compassionate right well just take
that and say okay instead of resettling
refugees against somebody's will because
you want to share what about somebody
deciding to share their car at an agreed
upon service or share their house and
the the left the political left has
fought against that vehemently it is
remarkably inconsistent proverb and who
is this they okay so borders Pelosi
Elizabeth Warren what they want to do is
either get uber banned in cities as you
see in cities like Austin or in cities
in Europe or they want to make sure that
unions that cab unions either get first
right or that uber hires these union
workers okay well I have a hit I
definitely am an issue with that yeah so
let's pull up that pull up that story
that Bernie Sanders is in favor of
banning uber Bernie Sanders uber and
let's let's break that down and unpack
it because I think when something comes
along that's better and it [ __ ] with a
business that is worse right the better
thing should win because that's progress
sure I think uber is progress I think
lyft is progress I think what lyft is
doing and what these these programs are
doing where you have an application on
your phone
you can turn it on and off anytime you
want you can work any time you want as
long as they certify and test you and
run and make sure you're not a crazy
person as long as they know where you
are at every time they can actually
monitor your location through GPS which
they can and everybody like saves money
and the people who drive the car make
money like you can make like thirty five
bucks an hour doing that well wouldn't
you rather do that if you have a car
like a Prius that gets 50 [ __ ] eight
miles to the gallon wouldn't you rather
do that so I'm in favor 100% in progress
and I think that anybody that opposes
that because somehow or another it's
going to challenge other people's jobs
right when it comes to something like
uber versus cab in my opinion this is
pretty black and white this is a new
technology a disruptive technology that
benefits a lot of individual users hence
it's good what also benefits the middle
class more than anybody and there's no
union for uber drivers there's no
lobbying and there's no money that goes
to politicians well that's the big
problem so I'm not aware of this you're
more balls-deep in politics than I am so
let's Jamie's gonna pull up a story and
we're gonna figure out what the [ __ ] is
wrong with Bernie Sanders take on it
from an individual point of view yeah or
you can look up I mean you can you look
up european cities that have banded or
auslan let's say I know it was a huge
issue in London I remember watching
those cab drivers that had decided to
block streets they decided to shut their
cars off in the middle of street and
literally stop cars from passing people
had to go way around them and it was a
huge issue
the reason the term political left and
right matters right now to me anyway may
not matter to some people but the reason
it matters to me is because you do look
at one side of the political spectrum
right now and I think the lines been
pretty clear in this last election where
there's an ideological divide and where
one is deliberately looking at
marginalizing and targeting and dividing
victimized groups and they do so and
ignore other groups of people who are
victimized as a result of them
complaining about victimization okay
like what this is that's very vague so
okay so I give you you want a concrete
example let's find this with Bernie
Sanders James guys like then what he I
find I find a quote about what he had
problems serious problems with it
serious problems with popular mobile
ride-hailing service uber speaking with
Bloomberg the Democratic presidential
candidate contender rather called the
service unregulated
wait
into one of the most closely watched
economic debates of the 2016 race
workers on demand at on-demand economy
companies like uber Airbnb or lyft are
considered independent contractors and
therefore do not receive the benefits
and protections afforded to full-time
employees okay
so I could see that but they do make
more money right is that correct yeah
well they don't they don't have to pay a
huge Commission to the cabbies union and
they're totally independent and they
have their own car and they make more
money I mean is that true maybe let's
make sure that that is true it doesn't
matter what room but let's just have the
choice - delicious Google uber drivers
make more than car companies versus how
much uber makes from their drivers
because that's the real issue like say
lubbers a company okay and they're
pimping out all these drivers and
they're making [ __ ] tons of money and
then they're not given the drivers
enough yeah they're given the certain
emotions I think they take a much
smaller Commission on it than the cab
drivers I reiterate I'm Pro uber 100% I
have a friend of mine is actually a
bigwig at uber I think it's great I
think even if I wasn't what's mad at
this how Oberer fails to prove its
drivers more than let's be able to prove
what does that mean I don't know there's
a claim and Huffington Post can't
disprove it but they're saying uber has
failed to prove it so this isn't gonna
calm that crowd or read the [ __ ]
crazy and defend your slow right wing I
am very right-wing
hand me that beer son time calm Oh
Reuben reveals how much this drivers
really earned sort of uber has long said
that drivers get paid more than
traditional cabbies but do they really
drive or surveys strikes and
class-action lawsuits suggest otherwise
most recently BuzzFeed is that okay is
it okay if it's but is that too
left-wing you [ __ ] yeah BuzzFeed is fake
news I mean you're fast estimation by
speed you fake estimate that terrible
trauma depression the drivers in Denver
Detroit in Houston make less than
thirteen point two five cents an hour
$13 25 cents an hour after expenses
using calculations based on more than a
million
well that's not good this spring uber
was hit with Q's class-action lawsuits
from drivers in Florida and Illinois who
seek to recover unpaid overtime wages
and other expenses this is after the
company this is our thing - shitty no we
have one shitty TV that can't handle an
HDMI cable it cuts out every minute now
we have one of those who seek to recover
unpaid overtime Jesus Christ unpaid
overtime wages and other expenses this
is after the company paid 100 million
dollars to settle similar lawsuits in
California and Massachusetts okay yeah
California Massachusetts big unions if
they have lawsuits and if there is a law
suit that does make sense enough where a
judge decides that they they're gonna
rule against uber yeah but this I mean I
don't know the law do you do you know if
it depends on a right-to-work state but
wouldn't you assume that the lawyers and
the the judges in Massachusetts would
make a strong enough case where they
would show the legality of it to the
point where it wouldn't lose $100 100
million dollar lawsuit no I wouldn't
assume do you know anything about the
lawsuit why here's what I would know
whether it's a right-to-work state or
not and that would determine the lawsuit
and that's why people like Bernie
Sanders and that's why people oh jeez
what happened there you open that too
fast just go do it I got scared it's
good enough and bro so what depending if
it's a right-to-work state or not I
don't care right okay they make less
than cab drivers I don't care well let's
salute illuminate people what is the
difference you know right-to-work state
in fact it means you don't have to join
a union means you can work without being
a part of the rubber Union it's just for
example that's when we do hidden-camera
videos we have to make sure that it's a
- about one-party consent state as
opposed to a two-party consent state
right like Nevada when they used to do
those prank call shows they would do
like remember Crank Yankers yeah yeah
they would do it in Nevada right because
because for Nia is a one-party consent
state no it's - well Nevada
nursing for Nia's one what do you mean
California when I dens in a definition
wrong and I'm thinking as we both have
to agree is that true yeah they would do
it Nevada instead of California right
that's what I'm saying Yeah right Nevada
you only like you can call me up and
prank me and I'm doing
I wouldn't have to agree right that
might have changed it might change for
example in Michigan it was really
controversial it was a one-party consent
state that depending on the judge read
as a two-party consent state so that's
really scary because you can be in the
clear right we recorded a prank call or
we found some kind of corruption and it
should be legal but there's a little
wiggle room where they can say actually
this isn't legal and you committed a
felony oh okay
so in these right-to-work states yeah
when you have this uber situation is the
issue that it's taking cabs out of
business or is the issue that they are
not paying people enough and they're
taking cabs out of business so people
like their cab drivers if they switched
over to becoming Ebor drivers they would
actually lose money because these
companies aren't regulated so they don't
have to pay insurance health insurance I
mean that seems like what the issue is
right that's what they would say the
issues are so not true well no it's not
necessarily true and again that depends
in the state so first off I would want
to clarify this people listening would
not be the right-to-work states the
right-to-work states would be fine
right right-to-work state means I have
the right to say hey do you want to work
for this amount and you have the right
to say yes non right too long it's above
minimum wage everybody's cool yeah as
long as I mean as cool as you can be
right yeah and what is a non
right-to-work stage is when profession
if there's an established union in that
profession you can't work outside of
that Union right that's is that the case
with trades like like plumbing being a
carpenter general auto repair yeah
generally speaking auto repair do they
have a union it depends on the state it
depends on the state but she'll Sonnen
actually would have some stories about
his dad being in the plumbers Union he
has some stories about that Vince Vaughn
had some funny stories about that he's
told actually when he worked at his
dad's like paper mill but but to go back
to it again first off I don't care
someone agrees to this price and this
service I believe that's a marketplace
of ideas and services and even the ring
to do it and I have the right to provide
those services now if Ober is doing a
poor job thank god there's lyft right
because there's some competition there
but if the government steps in and says
no you have to use the cabbies unions
well even then you can artificially
increase wages at the expense of the
taxpayer who now has to pay more for a
taxi ride so I don't care I think that
people should be able to make their own
decisions if they want to do
uber if they want to rent out their
house an Airbnb and I don't think that
Nancy Pelosi in the Bay Area
representing her district should have
any say and whether I can rent well I
agree with you 100% on that and I think
there's also a real problem people
resisting change because technologically
influence change is coming at such a
high rate there's no way you can put a
finger and all the holes in the dam it's
just you can't do it yeah there's too
many things that are happening they're
gonna change the way we communicate
change the way we do business change
everything from top to bottom you're not
gonna be able to stop it so any any time
you're trying to stop something like an
uber the only thing that I think is that
who you got to figure out where is the
house the money being distributed is
that fair and if it's not fair what's
the what's the solution because it's a
solution alert people to what the actual
numbers are and let it all sort itself
out or is it passing regulation I am a
firm believer that the less regulation
you have the better right and that's
what as long as it's not like
environmental pollution type [ __ ]
invisible hand right the mark that moves
the market I certainly believe that the
market is more efficient at regulating
itself than the government creating a
monopoly well also because unions can be
influenced and when you get large groups
of people together I think it's good
because like what a union can do is they
can say you know hey we're gonna stand
strong when I let these people take
advantage of us like some sort of slave
labor Factory in the Middle East or
wherever the [ __ ] it is we're gonna
we're gonna figure out a way to McCann
if you work here you're gonna get an
honest wage and I'm a hundred percent
with that problem is that you get giant
groups of people that you can't go
against someone's gonna be in control of
those giant that and that's no different
than being the mayor of a city or the
leader of a country no different than
being beholden to goldman sachs or JP
Morgan right and if you look at the top
political donors you can bring it up on
from open secrets if you look at the top
20 it's like 16 out of the top 20 are
big unions so this idea that it's big
banks and the Koch brothers and energy
companies no one wields more influence
in American politics today than big
unions particularly cuz mystic party
because its power and because they can
influence the people that also take dues
from you give it a hundred percent
Democrats
you have no say well it's one of the big
contributors to the war against drugs
one of the big things is happening in
this country is the prison guard unions
have spent money to ensure that
innocuous things like marijuana or they
stay illegal because if they stay
illegal then they keep their jobs like
they've literally fought for that like
fought to keep more people in cages
because that would earn them more money
I mean that's really what it is we break
it down to black and white and it's did
you just make a joke about the
discriminatory prison system in the
United States that was cold
I didn't say black and white because I
met black and white people I meant could
be black and whites matters the reality
of the situation is that prison guard
unions are spending money and using
their influence to ensure it didn't work
as an influence influence and like from
South Anchorage to ensure that marijuana
stays illegal and the reason why they're
doing that is cuz they profit off of it
so that's not an altruistic ideal that's
not some runners cares about the people
that they represent that's not someone
who cares about the community as a whole
that's someone who's looking out for
their best interests in a way that is
negative right towards the general
population with you and I think that's
where the wool was pulled over people's
eyes with people like Bernie well he's
from the people he's never gotten big
donors that's actually not true if you
look at the collective donations from
union members and from union
organizations and when you look at that
and what bothers me is when people
follow the money trail and only one side
and act as though the political left is
unbeaten two people that's the big point
what you just said on one side because I
think you can see the benefits and
unions as well you can see the benefits
in protecting wages and making sure that
people get insurance and making sure
that people live a good life that like
if you're going to work for this company
you're going to be well compensated and
you're gonna there's gonna be an
agreement between the workers and the
people that run the company well so the
problem with that and the problem with
this is but there's not always a problem
with that there is occasionally
sometimes know there's that that's the
rule rather than the exception I talked
about this what the Walmart CEO for
example makes 19 million right people
are freest about that well Walmart
employees 2.5 million people 1.5 million
people full-time so yeah that he's
getting less and then well if you add up
all all the workers not the full-time
workers would be less than $10 per
person he's employed
providing an active living so when you
have workers who say well he has 19
million that's more than I have I have
no million 19 is 19 more millions these
people who pick an arbitrary number
that's what Bernie Sanders are doing the
debate was Ted Cruz whether you like him
or not it was such a floor mopping
because Bernie Sanders dealt with these
phantom fears and again tried to
victimize groups and marginalized groups
in my point that I was talking about
there is for example we talked about the
victimized groups the marginalized
groups who don't have insurance in the
country right it was 40-something
thousand most of them were young people
who chose not to buy insurance so now
you can stand your parent's insurance
until 26 there you go we bought some
votes but you talk about them and
they're getting more affordable
insurance now and now the play is we're
gonna take all these people off of
insurance okay so we're talking about
that victimized group people who didn't
buy insurance but what about the people
who've seen their premiums go up
hardworking Americans 40-something
percent twenty four percent on average
in certain states 46 percent sometimes
sixty something percent their premiums
have gone up why don't we talk about the
ramifications of the everyday Americans
who now can no longer afford health care
insurance and don't qualify for a
government subsidy and if you look at
the trend I will argue this and I'll dig
my heels and if I feel I have to the
political left seeks to divide and
conquer and find for sure
the most victimized group of that day
well how so what do you mean the most
most victimized group with that day to
do what well I think well like right now
for example I'm just using that as an
example because you said a concrete
example with Obamacare so right now it's
these people aren't going to be able to
afford insurance well let's not go too
far away from unions okay we're way out
into the Obamacare pool well no because
deep and long no it's not it's really
not Obama cares you subsidize
health care subs cost other taxpayers
right who couldn't afford it and no they
can't afford let's let's start from the
beginning
cuz you went way out there and you
started out with the CEO I went out
there named Alex Joe and I went out you
went out there in terms of you covered
so many different things before anybody
could address either one okay you have
to like slow down and like take it point
by point you wanna you said this guy
makes so much money that if everybody
gave him ten bucks like why should they
give him ten bucks here's the thing like
what is this guy doing GLE big letters
lawyer of people in moment what
he's just a guy who works for them he
doesn't even own it why is this guy
makes so much money I'm not saying he
should I'm not saying he shouldn't maybe
he should make that much money right but
why defend that why defend that why not
well I got him see that's like that's
like you say can I get a raise and they
say no and you go away that guy makes 15
[ __ ] million dollars a year and it
doesn't even work what does he do is
there a lot of punch that's what you
just said there are a lot of assumptions
he doesn't work why does that guy make
that much how much the guy who sees this
the factory this guy's right have a real
job that much driven around a [ __ ]
limousine he gets 15 million we can't
get a raise
that's my point well you can just tell
them this is too much but don't you
think and this is what I think if that
guy really does make that amount of
money he's probably like how the [ __ ] am
i pulling this off always he doing
extracting numbers from some system by
his choice at all ones and zeroes and
moving things around and making sure the
profit margin trees and he gets a piece
of that and he just living like a
[ __ ] baller on a yacht a golden
bikini with a bottle of [ __ ] dumped a
crossdresser now having fun 19 million
dollars is here you do whatever the [ __ ]
he wants but there's there's room for
debate as to what job is worth there's
no job on my show of having people on a
disagree in engaging in those debates we
don't just say there's how do I make an
assumption there's room to your they do
how much a job is worth yes there is
room to debate so but it can be
determined by the value of a company and
the services rendered not some arbitrary
number because Bernie Sanders throws at
a percentage point I'm not saying that
he's right I'm saying well I think it's
totally within the interests of all the
people that work for a company that are
critical to this company actually
working to figure out like hey how much
should we get for this how much do they
get and well one guys getting 15 million
bucks and the other guys getting $15 an
hour and you got out like this guy if
this guy doesn't work this guy doesn't
get any money like these people have to
work if they didn't work the CEO would
make $0 right because there would be no
profit so someone has to work so I don't
think it's outside the realm of rational
discourse to discuss how much a person
should make to be a CEO
no I don't think it's outside the realm
of rational discourse I do think people
are wrong when they say for example to
take your argument how much a CEO should
make I think that's silly you shouldn't
be able to determine that just I don't
think should either just like I don't
think you should to say $15 an hour look
I think if somebody filets if some super
baller
you know [ __ ] Steve Jobs type
character comes in and starts running a
company and all sudden it goes
blockbuster through the roof and becomes
Apple I don't think you should be able
to say that guy doesn't deserve way more
money than the average person because
[ __ ] of course he does yeah that guy
is an obsessed genius who's making this
country which okay
exactly who does determine I think the
market does but isn't in a relationship
between the people who are this is
Bernie Sanders point of view I would
imagine right the people that don't have
a say the people that are there making
the least amount of money they're the
easiest to replace and they're the ones
that are worried about being treated
fairly well first off I would say if you
know therefore you don't care about poor
people well I was sleeping out of an 82
Datsun when I first lived in Los Angeles
so um I cared about myself let's put it
that way I used to be in high school but
I want to talk to those folks say it's
right attribute motive and I think and I
think we both might I think you don't do
it I don't do it I don't attribute
motive I don't say well you do this
because you hate poor people or you do
this because but you do have to look at
the numbers and you do look at a certain
point when people say they're
underrepresented they have no voice well
that's not true with union workers they
have a huge voice they have huge
political influence these people don't
not right voice came an industry they
have you know the entire music industry
has been so far left for so long pushing
for the same idea that country a lot of
those people are actually pretty fun Kid
Rock just talking about how most come on
sound very far left country music is not
far left so you take an extreme move
country the [ __ ] out of Dodge let's stop
you remove country it's one of the
biggest shaundra's in music in this
country not only that I bet they sell
more [ __ ] albums than anybody his
country going out there and making
redacted and Lions for lambs and
rendition and avatar and all these these
design anti-corporate screens the point
is I don't know what you're talking
about what do you see as countries
having one of them
movie is that what you're saying yeah
[ __ ] movie about aliens bro avatar
the movie is possibly the biggest piece
of neo environmentalist proper son of a
[ __ ] he's a [ __ ] amazing mom I got
blue aliens just out of boredom that guy
fell in love with that blue alien he
became one of them bro he was paralyzed
they put him inside the blue alien mind
if a James Cameron could buy an island
in paint people blue and have them run
around for the rest of his life if he
wanted instead he decides to print them
out on blu-rays using petroleum bro it
was a dolt movie and you're a [ __ ]
communist it's a [ __ ] great movie
enjoy no I hated it Christ dude is great
really [ __ ] flying dragons badass
Marines what else do you want what kind
of a [ __ ] in my talk you do what
happened to you you've been up in
Michigan too long it's too cold in the
winter it's too cold in the winter
therefore I need to like it bad for your
brain you don't think straight you just
want to stay home you like do you
actually like avatars of sex wait can't
wait for Avatar to really heard it's
underwater
even better they just stole that idea
from Mario level two let's make a school
Turin is a bad [ __ ] he's one of
the best directors of all times sure
he's a classic he's a great director I
don't care about his politics he makes
tea I was talking about the media the
entertainment industry the backlash for
someone who I'm not even a huge
supporter of Donald Trump neither one of
us are so they're gonna be relatively
objective so let's remove country but if
you look at the energy have you turned
on CNN recently drink slow down have you
turned on CNN raise yours cheers Cheers
well oh good drink it this is literally
like relax if you love me brother drink
it that was a dope movie it was horrible
the guy in high school if you love me
you'll drink it who the [ __ ] were you
partying with apparently Kid Rock being
considered as potential Senate right now
did you see that that I hold the [ __ ] on
is that true it's a bow hunter I'm with
him I'm voting for him actually I saw
his interview with Dan Rather last night
was pretty interesting yeah he's a lot
smarter than I think you'd I'd give him
credit for it he's not a dumb guy he's
not a dumb guy have you ever seen him
alive no I have not
I like what he does you know what he
does he put against of effort extremely
low ticket prices like 20 bucks or a guy
like him that's huge
sells out these places and he gets a
piece of the booze he's smart he's a
smart guy
even he's given his audience like a good
deal yeah makes a good deal with the
venue's like look if Kid Rock's showing
up this [ __ ] place to sell it out so
let's just make a deal let's make a deal
and his deal is is really smart I like
what he's doing well that's a good
example of a guy not being forced to do
it Yeah right he's just doing it because
he wants to do something that helps
people plus he's got a dope Cadillac you
ever seen his Cadillac I haven't had one
of them West Coast Customs custom made
Cadillac is this [ __ ] man where do you
goddamn impressive that he did it
remember that so I think if you got
started
okay sorted a beer company was called
like badass American badass or something
beer I like Kid Rock there I said it
these music dude no I like him and some
of his music is not bad I agree with you
some of us music is really not better
than popular to crap on him I like him
for that Cadillac
he's unabashedly friends with Ted Nugent
now you said the cars I love cars
because I remember I was listening your
podcast once and you said it's only to
the point when you make so much money
that you no longer care about money and
you use your car as an example you said
you know for example like I crap I got a
dent of something in my car at one point
would have lost my mind because that car
meant so much and now she's like okay
it's only a car so that was a good point
though that you made that when you have
enough money it's kind of like that's
what I call guerrilla Buddhism okay like
the idea of this is part of Buddhism
that you should not be attached to items
you should not be attached to objects
and you you know I have a friend of mine
who became Buddhist monk and he wouldn't
even have sex anymore it gave up on sex
all carnal pleasure all pleasure all
attachment to women attachment to
relationships and the idea is that you
don't want to be connected to that
because what you are connected to owns
you and my take on that was okay but how
does it have to own you like can't you
just enjoy automobiles can't you enjoy
an engineering you say that you can't
have a you know you can't own a thing
can't possess a thing I feel like that
is so ignorant of the world that we live
in it's so ridiculous you pretend you're
choosing to act in a way that you're
ignoring this
amazing technological revolution that is
going on right before your eyes and it
is going to [ __ ] happen whether you
ride a bike to work or not it's gonna
happen it's what people do we are a part
of this cascade of electronic progress
of electronic innovation and it's never
gonna stop
and that's and that's Santilli killer so
want to go back to that point the car
but you know that would be a good
analogy business because of iPhones or
we put you know there's nothing wrong
with appreciating things that people
make whether it's an automobile whether
it's a painting a sculpture
I feel like cars are like people look at
them as just transportation and I
totally appreciate that because the
works of art if you get a Prius it's
just transportation those are their
works of Arts if you get a 1969 Mustang
that is a goddamn marvel of time you
know it is a moment where people decided
to just create something that just looks
inherently like like collectively badass
there's no no one looks at a 69 Mach 1
and goes that's [ __ ] gross if you do
[ __ ] you know what that is if you do
[ __ ] you right if you look at a 69
Mustang you don't you don't say wow
that's crazy-looking that's amazing
isn't that a big irony that you're able
to appreciate it and not be attached to
it because you've been more financially
successful well that's what I say this
is this is the whole point of this whole
thing it's it's not a rational normal
position to take as most people are
behind the eight-ball all the time and
always need to pay their bills look at
that car look behind you sir look at
that guy yeah the ball cuts it and now
we talked about that earlier before you
were drunk yeah it looks nice that's a
[ __ ] amazing car man that 1969
Mustang is a marvel it all came together
it's just they figured it out they just
figured out some way to make something
that just is incredibly pleasing to your
eyes and doubles as transportation now
should get one right there's a company
that takes them and this is what I like
they take the the inside of it and the
engine all that stuff out and they put a
2012
be gt500 inside of it so you get like
anti-lock brakes
you get airbags you get everything yeah
and then they you know they put it
together and so that's the way to go
it's it's this was actually my
experience with very nice cars I want to
buy a car and I had very little money so
I went and I looked there was a 2003
Ford Taurus was like 60,000 miles on it
an old guy had cataracts so they took
away his license you know I can drive
and like no they took away his license
so I wanted to buy this tourist the guy
took like four grand for it not a great
car is getting you from point A to point
B but I had to walk through cars one
from George W Bush one for I can't
remember the singer there was one that
was the exact same model of car that
James Dean died in apparently they're
only like 13 horses Spyder you had a
Porsche but no no I didn't have it I
walked through it here's the crazy thing
wasn't this guy well let me assure this
guy who was selling this old 2003
tourist what are you a ghost this is
what he drove right but you know what
his business was his business was
customizing cars like that Porsche
Spyder and doing high-end cars people
like George W Bush the nicest cars in
the country and he drove a 2003 Ford
Taurus that I bought from him it's the
most it was just the surreal experience
walking through these cars that I mean
you don't even want to touch right you
want to put a fingerprint on it and this
guy I found out later was a
multi-millionaire it could afford any
car that he wanted he'd a 2003 Taurus
well some people do that because they
want to stay low-key and they just want
to just kind of chill yeah you know
there's there's that there's definitely
that like Henry Rollins drives a Mazda 6
he drives like a regular car and the
reason why does it is cuz he's just like
he's not he doesn't give a [ __ ] Henry
wants like sit in front of his gigantic
$200,000 speakers and listen to records
yeah he doesn't care about his car so
like for him it's like he doesn't want a
ball he's on a floss he wears the same
t-shirt he has like a hundred gray
t-shirts he wears the same thing every
day said well he's a fascinating
character in that regard because he's a
guy who has financial means like he's
very wealthy guy right but he chooses
not spending on things like that yeah
well it's like my dad gave me this
analogy one time we're talking about
cars or the ability to appreciate it but
you don't need it it's like air right if
you all of a sudden you stopped
breathing you don't have air all you can
think about is breathing right that's
the first thing we'll just lean you're
being suffocated by a 300-pound guy
inside control well
same thing with money if you take away
the money all you can think about is
money because you need money and my
point was like we were talking about
earlier we don't want people in those
positions determining exactly what I
have to do with my money firstly
personally as soon as you get money you
get this stress alleviation that's
palpable I mean I'm sure it's happened
to you cuz you've been really successful
over the last few years when you all of
a sudden don't worry about whether or
not you could pay gas bill this month
right it's a different feeling until I
was 25 years old every day of my life
was checked to check every damn I was
barely mean [ __ ] barely you know
lying to the landlord I scented what
happened you know everybody who's been
in that situation where you're like
literally wondering how much can I spend
today to eat you know and I've been I've
been there and then we all been there
the moment I got a development deal way
back in the day with Disney of all
people yeah of all people's I'm a Disney
show and they saw your set like no I was
boy pretty where you wanna be on TV
well it was you know 1993 or something
like that so I got a development deal
because it did an MTV half-hour comedy I
remember those shows I do I did one
episode of the MTV half-hour comedy hour
and I got a development deal from Disney
because of it I got like sort of thing
and there's they sent me some money and
as soon as they sent me some money it
was like literally like someone just
took a weight like lifted it like I was
carrying around a weighted backpack
right my whole life and they took it off
and it wasn't enough money where I was
wealthy where I could say I don't have
to work again but it was enough money
where I didn't have to think about money
for a year right and so all sudden I was
like wow this is what it feels like to
not worry about your bills like I've
never felt this before and then I became
obsessed with maintaining that position
okay once you realize that I was like oh
my god I'm a bulldog I'm gonna work
constantly I'm gonna wear I'm gonna do
stand-up I'm now I'm not quitting
anything
what could this why was that because I
realized how important it is to not be
dependent on anyone yeah to not to not
change like here's the thing about look
you're talking about Hollywood the way
people behave in high
it's in many ways it's a self enforcing
ideology in that you you know that
someone like Meryl Streep who gets up in
front of the Golden Globes or whatever
the [ __ ] it was and says crazy [ __ ] real
arts but right but when she's saying
that what she's doing is she's like it's
a war cry for for the like-minded yeah
you know there's no reason to say that
and for any other reason she's she wants
to rally the troops yeah she wants to
enforce her ideas and she wants to make
sure that everyone is on board and the
reason she said something she's royalty
is but she's Hollywood royalty because
and because of that she would say
something that stupid that was received
the way it was because she probably ran
it by a bunch of people beforehand the
point is not a single person there they
all roared and cheered come on a single
person there goes what of quarters
surrounded by people but what I'm saying
is yeah that those people that are
reacting to that they may agree with it
or they may feel like they have to agree
with it yeah I don't ever want to be the
guy who feels like he has to agree with
something right I grew up in a weird way
where like my parents got they broke up
when I was really young and we moved
around a lot and I didn't have roots
like I didn't live in one place until
Massachusetts when I was 13 right I
lived there for a long time that was the
first place I lived for a long time and
I got a chance to see the way people
cling to ideas versus actually believe
things and I think it's very important
to find out what you actually believe
and it's almost impossible in Hollywood
yeah because in Hollywood people have to
audition for things right and I've been
there man it's gross you go in this room
and some person looks at you and they
have a clipboard they're judging you and
they have power and the same power and
unions can control groups of people the
same thing can happen for really
self-righteous ideologues who happen to
be holding that clipboard well then
there's also the throwing out the baby
with the bathwater we're calling anybody
has a worldview an ideologue and I do
think that you're susceptible if you
don't have a framework from which you
look through the world if you have a
prism where you go okay hold on a second
if you're a hardcore do
died without any exceptions whatsoever
you're an ideologue if you start going
us-versus-them I can I've had
conversations with people in Hollywood
where they've talked to me about the
Democratic Party they go we have to win
the house in the house then we get this
I go what is this we man
yeah you make a [ __ ] cartoon but then
you have people who just go minutes left
in the right there it's all the same no
it's not you do need to determine a
prism through which you see the world
for example there's a very clear
decision you make do I believe in choice
do I believe in freedom and personal
liberty or do I believe in equal
outcomes and that doesn't mean that you
line up with either party the same on
every single issue but it is a filter
through which you will be able to see it
explain those options again you have to
make someone else to make a decision
right now why these three options you
said no I put two options and personal
liberty personal liberty and choice
right and choice freedom of choice or do
I value the idea of equal outcomes
oh well equal outcomes is ridiculous
because I can't play basketball but you
can't understand that unless you have
some kind of it people don't like
there's an ism there don't you think the
line things people need to play dodge
ball do you need to bring back dodge
ball you're gonna realize stay away from
that big [ __ ] that guy throws that
dodge ball it's gonna hurt when the
little kid gets hit Russian that's
really agent kid with the glasses that's
reading as soon as maybe that kids a bad
[ __ ] maybe he's from Thailand
maybe people wouldn't [ __ ] with him
since he was little
pretty rare catch him outside I'll kick
you in the dick how about that guy
possible that's entirely possible but
the point is there there is an ism and
people don't need to shy away from
saying you know what I do hazel there is
an ism what do you mean by an ism there
is an ism where people were conservatism
leftism liberalism I don't think
anybody's ever said there is just like
to act as though what cuz liberalism you
the first person is he left ISM I know
been alive for 49 years never heard a
single [ __ ] say left is well
because today's left is not the same as
classical liberals the word leftism you
don't skirt the issue yeah that might be
the first time anybody's [ __ ]
I don't think liberalism describes the
current you know
movement but people are people say well
I I'm not an ideologue well actually a
lot of people they don't realize they
are to some degree and you just have to
determine to which degree that is and
recognize that about yourself everyone
has a leaning well everyone has a MUX it
easier no it makes it easier to get
along if you subscribe to a
predetermined there's no predetermined
set of values or ideas if someone says
ok I'm looking at the world through this
lens do I look through it where we need
to ensure fairness and equal outcomes or
do I look through it in the idea that
people should be free to make their own
decisions that doesn't mean you're
subscribing to the Republican but are
you talking about your first initial
sitting well I'm talking about we're
talking about really recently yeah I
agree with you yeah yeah I mean I think
what we should do see I think a big part
of the problem with human beings today
is that it's not a fair hand of cards
that we're all dealt and some want to
pretend that it is it's not mm-hmm it's
just not and you know it and I know it
and we say well you know what you got to
deal with the best with what you've got
and I agree with that yeah the real
problem with that is the people that got
to [ __ ] ones those people more than a
problem well because for them the guy
with four aces just got Donald Trump jr.
you know he thinks you lucky
[ __ ] by the way Donald Trump jr.
is a very nice guy he's a sportsman and
a hunter you have to do now that he's in
a no I like him I use my friend I mean I
yes I mean I only text him but he's good
buddies so now we're gonna the forms are
gonna go nuts Joe Rogan Illuminati
Donald from said before I've said it
before I'm a very friendly guy every
single person that I know that has come
in contact with Donald Trump jr. said
he's a lovely man nothing but good
things about him he became more wealthy
when you became more successful do you
find yourself being more generous I've
always been a generous person but he
never I could be yeah because I realized
the importance of camaraderie I realized
because I didn't have a lot of friends
because I was constantly moving around
so when I had friends I valued them
greatly they were they were not
disposable like my friends to me like
they are as important as my family a
bunch of my friends have lived with
me yeah you know like when they've been
broke I like when I was single
especially like Tate live with me Duncan
live with me they were like I got
nowhere to go much [ __ ] you do come on
man so money justify your character
didn't change it well it it helped me
help people right when I had the
opportunity to do something look if you
see someone and they're a good friend
and you're you're you have a bounty of
wealth I could say a good friend is
hungry and you have all this food you
would have to be some kind of piece of
[ __ ] to say don't eat my food that I can
never possibly all eat myself right you
would want them to eat so you feel
better but my point is that's who you
are right and I said Joe has been
generous but you've been generous with
me in the sense of actually allowing me
on the show supporting content whether
people get mad about it or not and I
appreciate that but the point is the
money didn't change you at amplify it's
like alcohol it amplifies your character
you're not a racist and well I'm not an
alcoholic so it amplifies right and so
that's important people to note because
you have if you if you take that and you
believe that again as a worldview that
money doesn't necessarily it can doesn't
inherently change who you are you'll
find that you'll see just as many greedy
poor people as you will wealthy people
and that's important because when we're
deciding on some arbitrary number and we
just toss it to democracy you can have
just as many greedy portions of the
masses as you would big bankers and they
can just vote in their own self-interest
and that's not right either do you mean
by an arbitrary number like well I'm
saying what should a CEO make right
what's the fair minimum wage and if you
understand that there can be people
making less than minimum wage who if
they got the Joe Rogan they made their
break you worked really hard but all of
a sudden have millions of dollars
they're just as greedy as they are
making $13 an hour again it's no human
condition questionably you're correct
yeah that there are people that don't
care about other people's feelings no
matter what they make but I would say to
you give kids now you don't know I would
say to you as a parent that a big part
of that was how they were treated while
they were developing sure and there's
genetic variables there's people that
have illnesses mental illnesses or Zyzz
there's all sorts of there's all sorts
of variables when it comes to who is
steven crowder at 29 years of age who
are you how did you get to this point or
Who am I at 49 years of age how did I
get to this point
949 moisturise thought I was watching
the day where he lifted a kettlebell I'm
a strong [ __ ] I probably didn't
say that you did say that you said those
exact words oh yeah oh that's right he
was talking to me about like we're only
talking about 450 pounds like deadlifts
I'm like dude that's not that much yeah
450 yeah yeah yeah I am I had a knee
surgery recently and so for me I know
you went through the jujitsu drawbacks
and you got back in and blew your ACL
out
well actually I tore my LCL and the ACL
was slightly torn but they were like
actually the guy who does the surgery in
the Red Wings he came out he goes do you
wrestle I said yeah he goes okay we
rarely ever see an LCL that torn without
a blowing on ACL he's like did you do
anything where your ankle was going
towards your face guard pass yeah but
the problem is they went in and they
fixed that but that wasn't the real real
problem the real problem is my kneecap I
guess whatever it is the tissue that
holds that in place is gone and they
said it would be easier if you had a
torn ACL to fix because we know what it
is like with a kneecap take it out do a
replacement there's really a fascia
kneecap I mean they said so he basically
said there's no reason to do anything
with a kneecap because we don't know
what save their place it replace it with
an iron one yeah just start rich
Franklin versus Anderson Silva and just
rearrange his face that was so nice to
watch you know a lot of dudes wear steel
cups I don't necessarily think there's a
law against it in the UFC they started
making laws against it in Brazilian
jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu because he talked
damn I can't talk no no here's the deal
I had a buddy of mine did it to me once
my friend Amir Rena Vardy he got on top
no he got on top of me mounted me and he
had a steel cup on and he was
essentially [ __ ] my solar plexus
it was totally uncomfortable because in
a match
well it's it's metal I mean you have a
metal piece and it really affects arm
bars in particularly it creates an
unnatural fulcrum well a back take to is
really uncomfortable exactly it's going
into your lower regular cup like I use a
diamond MMA cup you know what those are
does it their completion
yeah they're in compression shorts and
the outside of them is like this
rubberized thing and the outside in the
front is all like a really hard plastic
like there's videos of them showing
people taking like full groin shots on
purpose you know with their
advertisements I can kick it really does
protect you in an amazing way but it
doesn't hurt
like a dot like one of those steel tie
cups so these dudes who are [ __ ] real
sadists they give these steel Tyco up
it's definitely an advantage and is that
what you think oh yeah well I think I'm
just gonna say Kenny Florian fought with
it I'm pressuring me pretty closely if
you [ __ ] mess up and you kicked Kenny
flooring in the deck you break your foot
kid that bar fight hey why are you
walking with a limp I kicked Kenny
flooring in the day I'm sure he doesn't
wear it to the bar I'm talking about it
in a cage you don't know that's a
judgment I wouldn't kick judge Kenny you
know but he wears tight pants there's no
way there's no way he's got a [ __ ]
crowd the local dive there's no one that
he's looking impressed as a married man
you son of a [ __ ] I thought you were
conservative any floor and dare you go
there I'm gonna take more tobacco and
packaging I don't ask that - kiss-ass
they look Joe Rogan so generous but I do
believe in again it going with the isms
general this is a message to people that
like wonder whether they should be
generous or not generosity makes you
feel better it does it just does like
it's not a selfish thing to like the
this idea that or not not necessarily
not a selfish thing this idea that to
keep your money yourself you're
protecting yourself you looking out for
number one it's not true right it's
little it's the wrong way to think
because when you're generous especially
when you're generous to friends it's
super important the people you actually
love that you express that to those
people when you do do that it's good for
you too it just doesn't seem like it's
good for you because people are so
survival or there's a great book called
who really cares
it's about famine mentality Brooks or
David Brooks but he went out kind of
seeing who actually donates and whose
generous and kind of going by political
persuasion by geographical you know by
just
let me guess conservatives to number one
yes so but but especially just once yeah
yeah yeah that is actually true [ __ ]
Michigan first off my home state
especially with jihadis out there you
know you've seen the Muslims but there
is the the ISM this is one thing that I
do that I do sincerely believe and this
is why I don't shy away from saying
listen I'm a conservative you said
something was pretty telling you said
because I really I wanted to work hard I
never wanted to be beholden to someone
again right so you made that decision
well you knew that if you did that and
you worked hard then you wouldn't be
beholden to someone else that was that
was the the assumption okay the
assumption that that is free enterprise
free enterprise or capitalism to use the
term right it can only work under the
under an optimistic society under people
believing they can retire and do better
socialism collectivism can only operate
by appealing to people's most selfish
nature by appealing to be able saying
listen the cards are the deck is stacked
against you you can't do this there's
someone else out there was an ace in the
hole you've been born without the leg up
that they have therefore I need to help
you that is the big difference
capitalism can only survive an optimism
whereas collectivism requires the worst
of human nature to sustain itself
maybe I believe that but what wouldn't
it be nicer if people just if someone
figured out a way to say hey how much do
you really need instead of saying you
have to do this and put people's what
I'm saying is can you contribute a small
amount that's not even affect you but
it's gonna help other people and do you
do that and if you do do that how do you
do it do you do it in the form of
generosity like do you tip waitresses
more than you should do you do it in the
form of giving out to charities that you
feel are very worthy and you know you
research them and you know the people
that are behind them do you do it in
terms of you know social work you do do
you do it in terms of putting out
informational videos that help people
figure out how they can advance their
own lives we all do in certain one I
know you do too
and charitable things amongst people we
care about when you address causes that
you care about you go out of your way in
a non selfish way right try to
illuminate certain things or add to the
coffers of certain organizations that
are doing we think are good good things
I agree but that should be enforced more
than the idea that some people are
[ __ ] you right right well I I agree
with you and that's again that idea like
you're talking about why are you giving
to this cause why are you why are you
donating your time right you're either
it comes down to either donating money
or time really at the end of the day
it's some sort of material goods or time
because you're doing it with the belief
that you'll help people it doesn't work
if you're being forced to because you
know there's some people to do it for a
tax break no that's silly no one gives
away a hundred thousand dollars to get a
forty thousand dollar tax break the map
doesn't it might have to if you want run
some [ __ ] LLC you might have some
weird GN LLC aren't you an LLC pipes
smell good that's um it's definitely way
better than cigarettes which shows you
how much the FDA has been [ __ ] you
well actually they've now pipes are
controlled tobacco product which they
didn't used to be but it's all the
chemicals that are actually added to
cigarettes what does that mean does it
mean hard to get there's there's
something ominous because with pipe
tobacco's a lot of these local like a
local tobacco shop they'll do their own
blends so they'll buy pipe tobacco in
bulk like that seersucker from someplace
in one of the Carolinas and I think
that's changing so it actually removes
the artistry where a lot of people like
this is this is the blend I can get in I
don't know you know Holland Michigan you
can't get anywhere else it's amazing
that's going away and what that does FDA
steps in is what does it do it favors
the big boys who send out their tins
from one centralized company the smaller
tobacconists can compete that's the
worry about marijuana well right if
it'll go legal you don't need these
dispensaries anymore right isn't that
kind of what'll happen they'll be out of
business
exactly it's a problem well what about
also people it's okay to possess it it's
okay to sell it or your friends can give
you some someone satisfying weed ever
got my yoga teacher gave it to me sounds
about right
how about
every time my wife goes in there trying
to give her some kind of weird incense
their newest every time she goes hot
yoga oh yoga there's always a difference
between essential oils and pot no not
pot but they're always got something you
know they want to put on incense or
something there's this my point my point
is you're beholden to the yoga
instructor so they use it sometimes the
salesmen sense my yoga instructors pure
and she's my friend what's what's
opposing with the pipe [ __ ] you can't
see when Joe just said [ __ ] you it
actually blew out his own lighter
[ __ ] you right-wing listen I mean I sit
firmly in the flip-flopping position of
the middle you don't know you're pretty
you're thinking you're pretty fair and I
do like to think that I mean it's really
hard to get leftist guests on her show
that's just a reality we try and book
them and then after a couple of times
well you know what's the most leftist
guess you've ever had well we had imam
Chaudhary who actually said I should die
on air whoa yeah he's the guy who now
he's in jail for for giving to Isis or
something from the UK so we had to we
had to create a whole new sky so you
shouldn't die on air why buddy say you
should die well because I did a Three
Stooges routine dressing up as maja
three old wife yeah it's not amazing you
should die for that you can die for
dressing up as a guy outside of that you
know Sally cone is pretty far left
Christopher Titus Michael jr. we tried
we wind them on the Christopher Titus
debate was one of the most painful ones
I've ever watched was it painful for you
it was because I felt as though I
usually do try and get into an
engagement of ideas and he was just
screaming so much um it was more pain
for him for me because I'm a dad yeah
and I think no something went wrong
somewhere along the line to get him to
that place where he's arguing about
something we really doesn't know the
facts yeah it wasn't it wasn't just that
it was when you were throwing out laws
regulations and he just didn't know
enough you know kept arguing about it
you know when someone's arguing about
something and they don't know exactly
what they're talking about yeah and
they've
down a dark road instead saying okay I
can't really talk about this because I
don't I don't have any facts at my
disposal
instead of doing that he kept arguing it
yeah and I was like oh Jesus and I
contacted you after all this bro this is
rough well you know you were very nice
about that you were very nice to him
while I was going on cuz it was [ __ ]
ugly
and you were very nice afterwards we
didn't gloat we had him back we had him
back one time Kevin chance and some
Commons antics he just gets so mad yes
Sally Kohn well he's saying you don't
care about dead kids that's the motive
thing that I'm talking about you think I
don't shy away from an emotive thing it
was it was it was a conversational
debate ploy he's like he it was a crude
debate the main point he's trying to box
you into a corner I want to say this
because I appreciate this fort Edison we
talked off-air he's a nice guy
whereas someone like a Michael Woods jr.
who refused to come on the show tried to
leverage coming on this show to debate
me is dishonest and someone who's afraid
or Michael Ian Black where recently got
into it with hopefully he'll come on the
show a lot of times get in there with
him literally I was on air and all he
did was we talked about this last in my
video and rape culture you saw it with
the Lena Dunham thing where it's one in
four women are raped and in the video I
literally say I'm not saying rape isn't
a horrible crime and those people should
be buried beneath the train tracks okay
okay I'm also not apologizing for I
literally say that in the video okay
okay and then I get into the stats as to
why rape culture doesn't exist in United
States and it does in the Middle East so
all Michael Ian Black tweets out is a
portion of that video a snippet that is
not the statistics that I presented but
that's a sketch cutaway it just tweets
out holy [ __ ] and this is the thing that
if someone sent that to him if he got a
clip it goes for they're just treats out
holy [ __ ] and this is the constant thing
right that often people who disagree
with me politically who identify as a
left go Crowder doesn't think there's a
rape culture and so if they say it as
though it's absurd enough people go yeah
that's silly but I say well hold on tell
me why I'm wrong and so I said well come
on the show tell me why I'm wrong and he
said well I wouldn't want to straight
white guys debating rape culture I'd
rather you talk with someone who's a
victim of rape or a woman would have a
better handle on it so I said okay how
about you talk with one of my two head
writers Casey or Courtney they disagree
with you they'd be glad to debate it no
I don't think is going to go and then I
had to call him out on air to the point
where he's agreed to
next Thursday but again the point is
holy [ __ ] this is absurd why is it
absurd tell me why it's I don't want to
show up if you have to ask then you
don't know and that's the position today
that we see on cable news that we see
from in this election but you
particularly see from people trying to
silence dissent I love the idea of as a
white man you shouldn't be able to talk
about this certain thing you should be
able to talk about bugs on Jupiter okay
it doesn't [ __ ] matter what your
sexual orientation is what your gender
is what your race is you should be able
to talk about things right just because
you talk to somebody about something
doesn't mean you the premier expert of
it right the premier you're the premier
expert of it no you should be able to
talk about things I think you're right
and that's a silly that's a silly
whether it's a plea to the left yeah
that that really is that's what that is
is you're saying things that you think
piece people could possibly criticize
you about right and you're cutting it
off at the pass before their
preposterous ideas get to you in your
Twitter feed well to me I mean like you
said you you disagree with people on
certain things but you're not a coward
ideologically I'm not I'm up physically
but you'll allow people on who you
disagree with and you'll change your
mind
I definitely changed my mind I'm not
married to my ideas as much as I get
criticized for that no I think I think
you're pretty consistent in that and I
think on the flip side what we try and
do is I say listen this is my bias this
is what I believe
what's your bias oh my god you said I'm
right-wing what do you serve but if you
had to like if you go god a minute and
maybe I went too far down this road if I
could just relax one aspect of my my
dialogue what would it be maybe my pipe
smoking your pipe smoking I probably you
know I probably wouldn't talk about the
marijuana issue that I wouldn't care
because you're something I don't care
about it
whatever the other but my issue with it
is when and we saw some Montreal I
talked about it when people lie about it
and they're dishonest with their voting
constituency like how so well saying you
know it's medicine for a B C or D it may
be medicine for a but not for B C or D
what are the B C's and DS example well
you're asking me what I wouldn't talk
about and I asked me to defend it the
point is I don't really care about it
but what are the B C's in deep well yeah
you said yourself answer
there has been shown it helps with
cancer about as much as american ginger
CBD has been shown with seizures
tremendous tremendous benefits for
cancer and non-psychoactive yeah and
surely with seizures i havent zero
problem CBD okay but much use of
cannabis yeah i feel the need to call
people out and [ __ ] when they say
well the reason it's not because of big
pharmaceutical companies go on a second
there are seven patents on chemical
compounds from marijuana right now right
the people who stand to make the most
out of marijuana legalization or
pharmaceutical companies that's why they
mess not true well it is if you look at
the biggest supplement no only by the
same pharmaceutical go you can't patent
the one way yes you can they patented
seven seven and leave hand her trains of
GMOs no no seven active chemical
compounds in part that have been
patented as drugs they've gone through
the process yes one that's really
efficient a point where you can't grow
pot how would you stop someone who's
legal it pots legal how would anyone
stand if they if that's the truth then
that's a real problem if pot is
recognized as a medicine right
if pot was recognized there is no one
who would stand to gain more than
pharmaceutical companies by providing it
is not necessarily true of people
allowed me really true I'll give you
that but I also think it's not
necessarily true that the reason people
can't smoke up is because big pharma is
sitting somewhere you know Martin's
correctly going let's make potty illegal
yeah well not that finally but there are
absolutely people who have lobbied as we
talked about how the prison guard Union
has lobbied to keep marijuana illegal
there's absolutely pharmaceutical
companies have done the same thing it
was revealed in the WikiLeaks memos this
is where I would say was told don't
interrupt me [ __ ] where Hillary Clinton
said that she's against marijuana in
every sense of the word right remember
those those came out yeah is he he said
he would leave it up to the states yeah
that's actually a constitutional
approach but he's pretty he wants to
beef up the war on drugs you know why I
bet someone slipped him a pot cookie
once and he looked at his hair in the
mirror and he's a teetotaler
he's even drink sold vodka doesn't drink
Donald Trump it's great yeah ever no he
says he Colorado topped 1 billion in
legal marijuana sales in 2016 good holla
yeah holla Colorado yeah
but another thing that we just wrote
about and get people
mad with the window shoes well no no
traffic fatalities regarding marijuana
have skyrocketed Google there cuz that's
a nonsense no drunk driving arrests have
dropped what do you mean you've what
first of all you wrote about what the
sources just because someone gets in an
accident and they're hi see you guys
hold on stop you just rocked way too
much the new stuff you talk no no I
don't talk about address I make full
points if people are high a lot then the
same amount of fatalities exist but the
people that get checked once they get
into these accidents happen to be high
it does not necessarily mean that
marijuana caused those fatalities it
could be that you have an increased
incidence of people doing marijuana and
altercations that could not have been
avoided it could be it could let the
statistical change is measurable well
what is free and you're talking about in
Colorado in states where it's been
decriminalized what's Colorado you said
let me make my point again my point I
don't care about it yeah you do
no I really don't you don't care about
it so touchy about it cuz someone says
you know what if we want to smoke up
fine I just don't really buy the
arguments that everyone is in some big
conspiracy to try and snuff it out no
there are yeah and the idea that the
drug war will end and the idea that it's
it's it's cures cancer I just don't buy
that I'm so upset
well we'll listen studies have proven
that it shrinks tumors that it helps
people with cancer
much like tumeric lot much like any
things that reduce inflammation in
community tart cherry right but it's not
necessarily they're all legal and
there's no issue because they're not
psychoactive right but they are
beneficial so all these things are good
marijuana is one of the things that are
good and free don't sure man just like
you don't sure tumeric you don't sure
ginger you don't sure a reduced sugar
diet all those things that reduce
inflammation or I don't I don't buy that
smoking marijuana would be as beneficial
as a reduced sugar diet and my point is
that people might owe offending that and
saying but if you want to smoke you
might be correct it doesn't matter
because it's not a [ __ ] contest to
see what's the most beneficial if the
question is is it beneficial and is it
damaging it is it does matter
what's damaged no no I mean let me
finish my point it does matter you said
would you not talk about I said probably
pot because I don't care well what do
you think about it and your eyes light
up and all of a sudden we're ideology
and world cares discuss like a tractor
beam on the most important issue of the
day that I said I don't care you're the
guy that thinks people should be able to
do whatever your market got so if you're
free market guy why wouldn't you be in
support of some thing whether it's the
most beneficial or equally but you're
not necessarily because you're friends
I'm just joking since marijuana
legalization highway fatalities in
Colorado are bringing up the source that
you want to flash the study right there
yeah Washington Post bring up a study
that we were we weren't about on our way
look I don't care about your website you
[ __ ] since marijuana legalization
highway fatalities in can you do this
with the crazy lady in a comedy club
funny you think if you scream enough
that it makes one my point is I don't
think that it would be enough and you
just said it was interrupting your
interrupted screaming because it's as
valuable as a low sugar diet and the
fact doesn't have to feel as though you
can't have a conversation about this as
civilly as you did every other issue
tells me that there's a huntress a
problem this is a TNT powder can this
humans I get very Defense and when
people start talking over me and you
started it first but the reality is that
a low sugar diet is fine it's good too
but why is there a competition between a
low sugar diet and tumeric and marijuana
and CBD oil why why why does one is
making the claim regarding legality that
it cures cancer illegal no my only point
is the other ones are already legal they
don't have to fight but no one's
prescribing no one's dishing out
dispensaries for tumeric or ginger they
certainly are if you go to these local
juice shop anyway you go to these juice
shops people are like crazy couldn't
care less people wanna smoke joints
you're an ideologue buddy really
that's an ideologue position by saying
leave it to the state yeah
you're locked in man really you're
locked deep into this [ __ ] thing man
I was raising a socialist profits of
your bread is buttered buddy a socialist
profit and once we're over here in
America [ __ ] just as much of an
immigrant as some dude who sneaks over
the wall Trump just built porn in
Detroit so and that remains to be seen
it could be a next mmm so horrible
Detroit have you seen that thing where
there there's a guy who is making a an
urban farm in Detroit
oh that's very common in Detroit now
well he's kind of the largest urban farm
and he's bought up all this land and as
he's bought up all this land he's taking
these like dilapidated houses they tear
him down he's building his farm really
cheap land and people are getting pissed
off of them they're getting pissed off
cuz this one guy now buys all this land
they're like well what about us yeah and
this is this weird thing that's going on
where people somehow or another are mad
at this guy who's trying to do something
positive if I'm not mistaken on that
story I could be wrong but urban farming
was a real we wrote about that when we
did this report in Detroit I was telling
actually Jamey about it beforehand we
did a real-time ride-along because
people said we selectively edited the
worst parts of Detroit so went back was
my producer not gay Jarrod we said okay
we're gonna start dead center downtown
Detroit where all the hipsters drank
their coffee and talked about how it's
being revived we will drive out in three
different directions we put a GoPro on
top of the car GoPro in the car a
mileage tab and a timer clock and it
never took more than about I think point
nine miles out of the city to certain
death an unbelievable urban plight the
crazy thing about Detroit is you'll see
downtown Detroit and then you look to
the left and it looks like the Upper
Peninsula there's nothing there it's so
desolate and if I'm not mistaken with
that story everyone was doing urban
farming but there were some problems
with the soil and sort of the guy who
probably found out he could make money
if he improved the soil and he got it
down to a system that was more efficient
and people didn't like that aspect of it
because now it's the big Herman farmer
right there always a wealthy guy who
bought up a lot of land right and he's a
white guy and he bought it up in this
you know really urban area and you know
the buildings were all [ __ ] up and
somehow and other people felt like
somebody was encroaching in their
neighborhood that they had watched
deteriorate no one there
there's no one there and though some
people are there but the point is they
felt like that should have been somehow
another part of their world which is
weird you know it's weird to think that
you deserve something because that's
where you live I think like we were
talking earlier about uber and all these
things change is a real part of being an
organism that lives on a planet right
and whether it's changed because of
nature like the [ __ ] shoreline
changes the ocean Rises tsunamis hit the
coast earthquakes change the landscape
with volcanoes whether it's that kind of
change or whether it's economic change
or whether it's technological change
there's gonna be change and if you're
trying to stop change you're on the
wrong side of history it's not gonna
work you're gonna you're gonna try and
it's eventually gonna overcome you yeah
I think you know my view is you should
allow people to be the change they seek
as Barack Obama put it and shouldn't try
to force change if you live in a [ __ ]
neighborhood and some dude wants a
breakdown the terrible house isn't build
a farm that's not necessarily a bad idea
no it's not at all yeah I mean when we
did our video in Detroit packs of wild
dogs roaming the streets in box real
yeah that's real and we got fact-checked
on it because we did a video on this
where we said you know packs of and then
I made a joke where I said apparently
there have been grizzly bear sightings
so hopefully this will be our next
National Geographic special some of
those black bear sightings right but I
got fact-checked I don't know if it was
backed in it I don't know remember if it
was Snopes or something someone saying
steven crowder made the claim that
grizzly bears were in detroit fact check
reveals that only black bears have been
the action they're like okay well you
should fact check them because black
bears are more likely to be predatory on
human beings than grizzly bears because
of more common interactions though
statistically you're very smart you're
right that's right kind of like sharks
it occurs in three to four feet of water
people are swimming exactly but that is
the case with grizzly grizzly bears are
way more aggressive yes to say but they
don't necessarily associate human beings
with food are you supposed to play dead
or run with a grizzly bear you wouldn't
know that problem it depends entirely on
why the grizzly bear is attacking you
the reality is if a grizzly bear is
attacking you because she's with her
cubs
you're better off playing dead you're
better off covering up me I mean correct
acting your vitals getting the turtle
position and taking your beatings and
she that's goodbye she's gonna [ __ ] you
up but she might leave you alone if you
just lay still and then she feels like
she can run away she's gonna [ __ ] you up
no matter what she's gonna incapacitate
you but if an old male or a predatory
male that has killed another human being
and recognized as human beings as food
yeah that has happened before where
hikers have disappeared and hikers
disappear all the time to the tune of
hundreds of people every year just
vanish
I read that actually polar bears will
stalk people well that's a different
animal yes polar bears are completely
predatory which means they don't eat any
vegetation you can get lucky with
grizzly bears where grizzly bears can
have a [ __ ] field of blueberries and
they don't want to have anything to do
with you because blueberries are
delicious they don't run and they can
just sit there and eat and they don't
have any hunger pangs really yeah how
many blueberries would it take to feed a
grizzly well this you know you're
talking about Alaska like a mountainside
like in the spring or in the fall rather
like before they go into hibernation
that's what they primarily eat because
all that sugar just gets like straight
into the fat their bodies and they store
it up big thick fat layers yeah but an
animal that has already killed a person
is where it becomes a real problem it's
not that animals are evil or animals
like no target people it's they
recognize food sources that they've
already eaten did you see those those
people who are protesting your meal
really mad the Rangers at Yellowstone
Park so they're very strict that you
cannot feed the Bears you can interact
with them and what they do is they had a
bear that wasn't necessarily aggressive
they do this all the time but there's
some specific instance that piss people
off wasn't necessarily being aggressive
but learned that people would throw food
at it and so well not only do we not
have that bear doing it but we can't
have other bears seeing that bears an
example so what they do their first step
is taking the bear far away you know
somehow transporting them sedating them
and if it comes back either a second or
third time they euthanize it they have
to yeah and all these people were
furious no go no no we're doing this so
that the Bears don't become dependent on
humans for food
if you euthanize one bear that prevents
the rest of them they no longer can
forage can hunt for themselves because
they realize these people gonna throw us
a sandwich
and that's a great example of just
people not knowing not being informed
enough on an issue and instead deciding
to be outraged like I don't know about
grizzly bears I assume the Yellowstone
Rangers kind of have their crap together
on it well that's also like PETA people
that don't want to admit that PETA kills
thousands of cats and dogs every year
and their heads a diabetic who uses
insulin which came to you courtesy of
animal testing yeah but she feels like
that's okay because she's she's skinny
fat but there's a great podcast that's
available right now the most recent
meat-eater podcast with Steve Rinella
where he talks to a bear biologist who
discusses the history of Yellowstone at
one point in time the dumps where people
and restaurants used to dump all their
food it was places where people would go
to watch to watch bear we did it at a
campground Wow it was like that year was
this gosh 90s but where were you not in
Yellowstone no it was in Canada okay
they'd already made it illegal in
Yellowstone I fear no bears when we went
we just drove by there was no one but
it's like if you go down into this area
it's really cool you get to see the
Bears foraging one thing the hosts own
it was one of the main like like
mortality like you look at like
mortality events yeah it was a huge
mortality event because they went cold
turkey
they stopped dumping all the trash there
and these Bears had become acclimated so
much so that they'd stopped learning how
to forage food and bears died like
unmask yeah it's really kind of crazy
that's also the flipside you know with a
rescue dog where I tell people like we
have a rescue dog people get so fed and
willing to say but if you have kids
probably better to go from a breeder you
know because for example hopper on the
road we don't know you know we don't
know what happened to me happens to be
the most affectionate loving dog that
we've known but a dog like that that
starving can learn to become much more
of a wild dog you know that can be
trained in them cuz they're scared
there's they been scared and you bring
him in for example he gets recall any
gun ever since we've had him any handgun
rifle pull it out goes nuts so he's seen
gun he's seen something in a negative
conversation with guns you can't know
that so if you have some kid and he
pulls out a squirt now he's not
aggressive he's just to bark if he
doesn't look like something and people I
don't know if was
ptoo some animal person got really mad
well there are so many dogs I need homes
I'm gonna listen I've rescued a dog I
think if you know what you're handling
you should if you're able but if you
have kids who don't have a lot of dog
training and you don't know where this
dogs come from I place kids higher on
the totem pole than dog how dare you
you're a species I know I have a species
this that's a new thing
there's speciesism when we were kids
Jamie you younger there was that film
species where that blonde chick that's
different
where'd she go she quit I know she's
probably doing stuff to pornography well
how dare you
maybe she's writing books well the the
the grits oh I don't know I've never
thought of black bears as being
aggressive toward people yeah man
Rinella the same guy who has the podcast
I was talking about told me a story of a
guy who went on his very first hunt and
while he was in his tent a 500-pound
predatory grizzly bear attacked him his
friend shot the bear and hit him in the
wrist the bear takes off out of the tent
goes to another dudes tent and they
shoot it in that tent to kill it so
everyone's covered in blood and hair and
it didn't kill it yeah they killed it
but I mean the guy had a bullet wound in
his wrist he had been mauled by this
bear I mean this is his first hunting
trip ever could you see that the
Reverend yes you know there was a rumor
before that film came out that no
Leonardo DiCaprio gets raped by the bear
did you mom that was front page and you
are on the wrong web it was front page
drug exactly people wrong and I remember
thinking about that never watching it
going this is an example of fake news
whether it's the right or the left is
going this is clearly not a bear rape
scene but it was a huge rumor that was
going around poster don't don't go see
the red wasn't huge enough to reach my
twitter page well you have a big Twitter
page he's just too into it man you're
too deep into the news of the world I
told the story Chris Leben at the Reve
reverent revenant revenant in so we're
there this is I swear this is true and
Chris Lee even thought it was faking
faking so we're watching the revenant
and it's right up that scene where he
cauterizes his wound with a gun powder
on his neck so we're sitting there and
we're watching it and he's screaming and
so for a second we didn't realize it a
few rows down a guy's
all of a sudden starts projectile
vomiting while the Leonora's on three
one and we're looking and we're gonna oh
my god we think he starts shaking we
think he's having a seizure my wife
being a sweeter goes okay everybody move
away someone call 9-1-1 and his his wife
or his girlfriend there's like sweetie
Arizona and it's going down to Rose we I
go I wait for the ambulance they come in
the guy has vomit all over him I think
someone who's sitting front of my bottom
on on the back of his head they thought
for sure he had a seizure turns out he
had fallen asleep and inhaled a popcorn
kernel hmm and he was just choking a
Norfolk time and then aspirating on his
own vomit so we're watching this film
the revenant one of the most graphic
scenes in cinematic modern history what
the hell is going on
Wow and a coincidence yeah and it was I
mean the guy was embarrassed he just
fell asleep it was a scene like remember
that movie what was that movie with not
Matt Damon Matt Dillon well it was the
movie where the two girls are making out
by the pool oh yeah what if he watched
that movie
what if that scene was going down that
popcorn kernel got stuck at his mouth he
started projectile vomiting why would
that be worse if you way worse just
because it makes sense like the guy's
scared there's a bear he's killing
Leonardo DiCaprio no don't kill Leo you
know don't do it to him he's a king of
the world he's in the front of the
[ __ ] Titanic don't don't do it
you know people freak out and like a
bear attack but if you're freaking out
like a lesbian event it turns out just
coincidentally just pieman the story
people gonna tell about you for the rest
of your life yeah Bobby saw these two
broads making out there were choked on
his punch alone he's lumps by himself he
just starts hurling changed his life bro
said he took them popcorn but we know
that
never I've never seen like I mean from
here yeah that like to go to static
taking up the kid in the pie-eating
contest and that Stephen King boom we
stand by me remember that oh yeah yeah
very pie contest because it wasn't like
a Oman flow it was pressurized it's
funny because he was also holding his
mouth so it's coming on through a crack
you know like this where it's going at
squirting so we fell asleep with a
popcorn kernals mouth at the revenant in
the middle of that [ __ ] really
exciting movie in the middle of that
scene right where he's cauterizing his
own ass neck [ __ ] I felt bad for him and
imagine that if that if that wasn't his
wife that was wasn't his fiancee there's
a good chance they're not together did
you think that movie was based on
real-life events we have no idea was it
supposedly
but incorrectly oh really yeah it's not
somebody sounds like I already have oh
really
didn't happen in an environment anything
like the environment they filmed it in
they filmed it in this like tropical
rainforest in British Columbia the the
guy never had a son when Leonardo
DiCaprio son is killed in front of him
the only thing that was true is guy got
mauled by a bear made it back to camp he
actually survived he made it back to
camp that's and he's like what the [ __ ]
bro the guy's like sorry I thought you
were dead that's it that's the movie the
entire teaser was the lead up to the
bear attack and it was him going back
and killing the guy who left him behind
who also held his son there was no son
nobody killed anybody they [ __ ] up by
a bear and they left him alone that's
interesting when you think about that
you know you go back and do you like
Weston Price you know at Weston Price
foundation or did he like the fermented
cod liver oil and stuff and they their
big catalyst for like eating real fats
and stuff and the guy claiming aware of
this was yeah I think was less than a
price foundation and we're advert
advocates traditionally or DeLong's
around for a long time yeah guy I think
his name is Weston Price and because I
always watch those movies like the
revenant I go could you imagine how much
it smelled and imagine what their teeth
were like and this yeah but this guy
claimed he went down to like you know
third world sort of African nations
where they didn't brush their teeth but
they had perfect smiles and he claims it
was because I don't know how I don't
know if it's true at all but he says it
was because they
a lot of organ meats they were getting a
lot of vitamin K natural vitamin D as
opposed to kind of the sugary lifestyle
which refined carbohydrates in the new
world and that's a big part of like this
whole kind of high saturated fat organs
bone broths it's called like Weston
something price foundation but remember
there were these pictures side by side
of people in the new world were in
largely grain fed diets and these people
were basically third world sort of
tribesman but that these beautiful white
teeth that make sense in some ways that
people that live natural lives with
natural foods than anything processed
would be healthier yeah but the teeth
now there were nice white teeth well for
sure definitely deteriorates your teeth
we know that we know that kids we eat a
lot of sugar and don't brush their teeth
and I think a lot of that was also that
stuff getting caught in your gums and
your teeth and just not good causes
sugar it causes tooth decay
we know that yep and the worst thing is
sugarfree gummy bears you read those
reviews on Amazon God what do they do to
your [ __ ] that's exactly what the
reviews are on Amazon I swear to you if
you just google sugarfree gummy bears
just like my Apple has never been the
same size since it's just a bunch of
people who trolled the Amazon afternoon
read the Amazon reviews for sugar-free
harrybo gummies remember olestra there
was an additive to like potato chips
olestra just makes people just rock it
[ __ ] well trans fats are now they're
illegal but you have there was a grace
period until 2018 I believe or maybe 19
right where companies are allowed to
still use that stuff and their potato
chips or wherever the [ __ ] they sell up
until like then like that's it like you
poison people for two more years that's
it well you know why we use terrible for
you because of the same environmental
vegetarian lobby who you know back then
McDonald's use beef tallow from their
fries there's no no you need to be using
vegetable oil hydrogenated vegetable oil
so that was a bunch of lobbyists no
that's why we started in trans fats and
now they're going actually margarine as
not as good for you as butter and
they've changed but that was a huge
powerful lobbying group where the veget
you know the San Francisco kind of
hippie era that's why trans fats became
ubiquitous well it was also a byproduct
of the sugar industry arriving
scientists to lie about the beneficial
qualities of their sugar they just
pretended the church fine its saturated
fat that's the issue and everybody wants
[ __ ] we got to get some margarine yeah
these people went out and bought margin
because it terrified of saturated fat
because the sugar companies had bribed
some scientists weird that when we were
kids Country Crock margarine we didn't
help so bad for you it's interesting now
that that's been revealed and you find
out that those people didn't even get
that much money they got like the
equivalent of fifty thousand dollars
today right - literally lie to everybody
about the the the they just made up a
bunch of [ __ ] about saturated fat yeah
and they they just diminished all the
negative effects of sugar and people
just started drinking that the milk from
Captain Crunch
remember that milk we get that [ __ ]
sugary Captain Crunch milk or salacious
hops it's absolutely delicious you get
the chocolate milk out of Coco Pops yeah
oh my god Count Chocula
oh my Jesus good we grew up on sugar I
know and in Canada we we had a whole
different I didn't realize I moved to
the states corn pops in Canada are
actually like spherical Captain Crunch
they're not at all like corn pops in the
states there are a lot of little
differences because it's such a silly
country where you'll be raised there and
you'll coming up like the Oreos aren't
the same super sugar Crispin's sugar in
the title that's the sugar crisp here
right yeah yeah was enough of that sugar
Chris that's right super sugar crisp you
imagine you have a goddamn drug in the
name of your [ __ ] look at there you go
that is crazy it's not even good it's
illegal you go to jail if you even sell
that super sugar bear does the sugar
bear um yeah I mean sugar Chris yeah I'm
a strange Mongoose then I'm a mongoose
with the t-shirt ah then there was
cookie krisp remember that cool
cookies in milk but then there was
Reese's puffs cereal look at that one
smacks they have an Indian a cultural
appropriation today look at that
what does it have to do with a Native
American what smacks why it's like
Latinos selling cars they just put tits
on it because it sells in their culture
Oh inside is a free Indian car that's a
special Indian some of them make an
acceptable they created the Indian card
so it's just as bad no it's fine frosted
flakes go down to frosted flakes over
there they stop there right yeah 1950
vitamin D yeah throw it in there there's
no natural smell in there yep milk [ __ ]
the kids gonna get sick from sugar what
kind of [ __ ] shitty kids are you
raising Reese's puffs cereal that was a
big one everyone Reese's puffs lose his
penis in a cup cereal yo that's you
never had that no that was a little
later than you I guess you might have
been illegal in my country they might
have been looking out for our best
interest by the I remember because there
was a there's like a fat black kid from
hanging with mr. Cooper who did the
commercials in Canada for reasons that
Reese's puffs cereal who were sitting
there as this kid he was in hanging with
mr. Cooper and so as a kid you're like
well we watched that show on TGIF we
have to get Reese's Peanut Butter Cup
Series gif up there that was doing that
was a sin thing ABC you know hear it's a
[ __ ] place at Soldier yeah yeah bad
wings too they're pretty bad in Kansas
you're on the road it's true TGI Fridays
what's the big deal
banding in is is coming back to
Bennigan's is back don't you remember
they were gone away because it was like
well okay Bennigan's we can do without
notice I mean they went under and then
they came back you up they were gone now
they're back I don't know why huh whole
new brand probably investment bankers
probably some dudes from Marin County
it's the globalists wires wireframe
glasses those [ __ ] skinny jeans well
we're trying to do is bring back a
really recognizable brand it's really
important to America have you read we
shall feel and we understand people try
to come in and be like listen we can
take your show even bigger
we just think there are a few tweaks you
ever get those people who approach you
Oh which is interesting really
everybody's like no no no Adil Kroll
they got him though huh they did no no I
did I did his show once and it was uh it
was the most awkward thing I've ever
done in my life why was it so awkward
well cuz the Booker's I was doing Prager
University it's like oh hey I know hook
you up
and um first off he's like I don't
Crowell is he's not like you like come
in and you talk off fair he kind of like
doesn't doesn't really talk to you and
tell your on-air mm-hmm which I can
respect its professional but I wasn't on
the Adam Carolla podcast it was Adam
Corolla and dr. Drew had reunited to do
like it wasn't it's not love line but
it's effectively the same thing right
and so they still do that back and that
was their first week now is there for
like the first week they brought it back
and so it's him and dr. Drew sitting
there doing their stick at a table and
I'm literally at the end of the table
with nothing to say like yeah that
sounds about right they're taking
callers from people didn't and bring you
in a little bit but it just you know I
Adam Carolla does his podcast like this
was an interview and that was just it
was really weird and I think what
happened was they didn't realize he
wasn't doing the show that day and they
brought me they were very nice dr. Drew
and and Adam was gracious afterward but
it was it was clear like it's a two guy
show taking phone calls and you were
just there yeah I was pretty much today
they say your name no no they did they
did but it was like hey I want to take
phone calls well Adam does essentially
does an internet radio show that's what
his show is right you know I mean he was
he had his radio show that was a big hit
radio show and then the station went
under in LA and I think he just decided
to do the same format and just do that
same format online yeah that makes it
when we started our show you know it's
syndicated and so we had radio and so we
had all these commercial breaks we used
to do at 6:00 a.m. on Friday mornings
out of Detroit and what we do well no
one really cares about these commercial
breaks nationally so we just did a bunch
of sketches and fake commercials and
that's what created all these characters
that people have treated these Twitter
profiles for because we just said well
we're not gonna run an ad for a local
car dealership we're gonna do a fake
news break and we would do like fake
tornado warnings and stuff like that
which is highly illegal by the way we
learned that one later on because they
kind of work with the format online and
now we just took it off took it off
radio yeah
[ __ ] radios much dying market that thing
is not gonna last it's stupid was last
time you turned on your radio I have a
never yeah I found remembers another
person I think in like all the cells in
your body except your neurons switch
every 7 years that means every cell in
my body's never listened to the radio
that's [ __ ] real man it's like if
someone said to me when was the last
time you watched a VHS cassette I was
another person yeah I wasn't even me I
don't take responsibility for me of 14
years ago because if I did I would still
be pissed at [ __ ] my pants when I
was a baby okay cuz I would take it back
to when I was three and I bit my sister
or something I don't know the [ __ ] I did
but you know I mean figure I'm I don't
know I don't remember three is my point
it's like if you go back to the things
you did when you were developing
individual yeah so I feel like every
seven years I don't even want I don't
even want to know yeah what I did 14
years ago three it's pretty rough years
I called my dad's pastor a little
bastard three you're probably right well
cuz my grandfather called me a little
bastard right I thought it was a term of
endearment and somebody is like this is
Esther Kevin butcher hey how you doing
little bastard
well that pastor should have known this
little kid is getting [ __ ] over at
home no you know what happened actually
he got outed and this is actually a
point gay no no he got out from the
church because there was a his pregnant
I think his pregnant wife bomb which
wasn't a Detroit Lions game and there
was a guy with a bullhorn behind her
right up against her ear where this guy
was a pad but a really good guy
regardless of someone's you know
religious affiliation but a good guy and
he's like hey man could you stop my
wife's here you know whatever she was
either pregnant or something guys looked
into it and kept doing it right next to
his wife's ear like got it right up on
her ear
and he ended up kicking the guy's ass
getting into a fight with him because
the guy was getting up on their space
and get didn't exactly turn the other
cheek he did not he did when he asked
him to and so there was a whole vote and
I remember that was that was when I was
pretty young I thought well so they
outed him they got rid of him meaning I
could be wrong there was a hole up there
was a whole controversy over it and I
remember learning about it as a kid
thing well that's that seems pretty
reasonable the guy getting up and his
wife's grill and bothering a pregnant
woman yeah it's like what do you do
because human nature is definitely to
hit the person but do you just leave
you know because your night is ruined
yeah period well I said kick his ass I
mean I think what happened was no no I
don't think he kicked his ass I'm saying
but you got physical and he got physical
with the guy and got the better of him
so it could have been a shoving match
could have been a punch he didn't beat
him it was an American History X curb
stomp I'm just saying no one expected a
pastor to do anything to Bry his wife I
get it yeah and that was a big deal I
called a little bastard
hmm that's the end of that rabbit trail
well you were right once he got kicked
out the Crowder kid he's got vision he
sees the future there's no one places
he's knew that guy was a brawler he's in
[ __ ] bleachers brawler gets up there
get slick it up [ __ ] his wife gets her
pregnant tension to the game that crowd
has gone flat he called it he's gonna go
to Fox News for four years
hey most four years of his life I saw
him on this show once with Amy show me I
get with it oh I took your side yeah I
get with it what did she do she you guys
were on some show and she was trying to
like diminish you as a comedian yeah she
was trying to say you weren't a comedian
yeah and then an interesting thing I
said there's like a thing that people do
in the world of stand-up comedy where
they just say oh he's an opener he's a
middle act right you know like there's
like there's just weird sort of a thing
and someone like if they're looking like
[ __ ] on you all you do time you do
comedy yeah are you do comedy yeah what
are you done he'd do a few open mikes
like you're a [ __ ] comedian yeah I
really it's very very luminous like that
yeah she did that right off and I knew
it because she was asking me questions
in the greenroom like where do you where
do you do comedy what do you do and she
was like she asked me what do you
perform at churches I said no I said no
I never have and she but she was so
inflexible an argument she was old women
maybe 20 to 23 probably would have [ __ ]
on you too dude probably what I would
write next to that changed if you look
at the Rihanna Amy what a [ __ ] dog
tag do well no I don't think so
it changed round things so what do you
think would happen you would one that
well I think I think if you to bang your
head it done really well yeah yeah I
think I think if you watch that thing
her argument was you're not a real
comedian I would have never said
information and
Schumer's a thirtysomething year-old
girl who [ __ ] the people on twitter
now and is unmarried and miserable are
you comparing lives I am I am and I
think I was right well I think that
whenever someone announces she's funny
by the way
okay good for you I think whenever
someone says that you're not a comedian
thing that's yeah that's an issue I have
an issue with that because we all
started out as I opened my curse and
when you're talking to someone who's 22
years old when I was 22 I was an open
mic er I was doing open mic nights like
this just for laughs at that point so it
wasn't open my career yeah I mean and
you know I had okay were you getting
paid you will you have factional
community your making your living off of
stand-up comedy I've only made my living
ever off of acting stand-up comedy
writing since 18 years old Wow
so when you were 22 years old all your
bills were you live on your mom what's
going on
how you paying your bills at stand-up
comedy we're 22 so I was I was I would
do stand-up then I had some pretty
relatively successful acting gigs did
some films commercials some TV at that
point I was a Fox News contributor which
paid me a retainer I did freelance
writing where they would pay by the word
so you were doing stand-up on a regular
basis see you were stayin up calm I
don't do it much anymore I would readily
admit like now I don't because the show
and everything is a 14-hour day right
now I would never claim to be as good of
a stand-up as as you or Nick DiPaolo or
a builder by the way but Nick DiPaolo
asked me to plug he's doing his
substantives but yeah Boston
yeah his stand-up special is going on
see so this Thursday so please go he's
probably the best for my money one of
the best living comedians certainly one
of my favorite Nick DiPaolo was goddamn
hilarious and he was here yesterday and
he [ __ ] killed me he's a he's a very
fun in a very very very good dude and
another weirdo right-wing [ __ ] yeah he
is but it's pretty common Christopher
Titus did the same thing that was the
same thing we started losing the gun
issue I get paid first
oh well you know what that's he what he
was doing was trying to save whatever
was going on in his mind or there's a
conversation where there was a
competition whatever the little
battleground and his mind was going on
he was trying to save his his patch of
land well I think and I think it would
work with most people I think you would
probably go there's a lot of stand-up
comedians they they have a void and
they're funny this has becomes their
identity
and so for me it was never my whole
identity wrapped up and stand up I mean
I had been doing acting since I was 12
years old and I was tutored on set with
a lot of things you know I did kids
cartoons that show Arthur's how I
started out so I did stand-up and I'll
be the first to admit I did it as a
means to getting to other avenues and
then I turned out I fell in love with it
but I never plan on doing stand-up my
whole life so if I were I'm a stand-up
comedian I'm a road coming I love being
you know waking up for leftover drugs
and being unhappy and bitching about my
manager leftover drugs have you ever
heard of such thing yeah yeah Turkey
Oh drugs yeah whose charge this the
pride and stand up of barely getting by
kind of like New York right you're in a
shitty city in a two-bedroom apartment
with five roommates right and you're
proud of it because you can tell
everyone how miserable you are so just
that's not real oh yeah no no it's real
once you become successful it's never
real while it's struggling and people
try to act like it is right like oh man
I couldn't do anywhere else it's the
energy of this city it's like you
literally [ __ ] in a drain in the kitchen
you know and those in the Lower East
Side you're seen as what's that Lower
East Side it's like so saturated I am
NOT small right wing right wing people
are always exaggerating I look at
mentoring in the East Village cuz they'd
have like nineteen polish family members
per apartment and the toilet was right
in the middle of the kitchen because
they weren't designed sometimes you have
to dig a [ __ ] there's one for mom while
she's making spaghetti they're
multitasking she could squat it's got
one of those little squatty potty things
you ever seen that one sign like you go
to some places it's freaking did buy too
many people from Asia you'll see signs
that show like person standing on the
[ __ ] squatting down it's like I got a
red line through it don't [ __ ] Raceway
yes
pull has it become that popular squatty
potty I've seen it I've seen there's a
squatty potty yes I do
and I would assume so comes the caveman
thing the bowel movement well if I
prefer to [ __ ] in a hole in the ground
in the kitchen time to dig like look at
the guy no no
right that would just isn't joking one
this is a joke one but I have literally
seen that that's real that is an actual
real for people in Asia
Ari Shaffir went to China and he has
this [ __ ] hilarious bit about it and
I don't want to I don't want to do his
bit that's that's real but in China he
went into a restroom and there was
literally a hole in the ground and you
were supposed to squat over the hole and
they had no toilet paper yeah that is
real and he told me that when people
from Asia who were used to that
environment as the norm come over to the
United States sometimes they actually
stand on the toilet seat and and [ __ ]
that way so the toilet seat is not
designed for the aim to be accurate if
you're if you're sitting on the toilet
seat you'd be crapping on the water tank
they don't know any better bro they're
from another country without Trump
without Trump leading them they don't
even know anything man tossing defending
Trump I think do you think he's a good
leader are you happy that he's in office
are you is it good this shake up I will
say this I I I think that again the left
has behaved so poorly and with this like
yeah yeah I think that Ron Donald Rome
has been a lightning rod I would
disagree with him on some policy issues
for sure but I think that because
everyone has called him a not seeing a
racist and a sexist in a trans folk
that's removed those arguments from the
table for for at least several decades
because people going yeah but you said
it about John McCain and Mitt Romney
everyone you disagree with his a racist
I think that cards been played too much
and because of Donald Trump it's been
overplayed and I think now we see with
our channel granite it's not as big as
you know the outreach you guys have but
it's grown pretty substantially and a
lot of our audience are self professed
liberals going you know what I used to
hate you I used to I used to watch The
Young Turks and then we used to watch
them crap on you but actually some of
these points make sense and I used to
think everyone disagree with me lose
racist and I think because it's so
overplayed it's left such a bad taste in
people's mouth I do think that Donald
Trump has served a real purpose to shine
a light on that and you know that may be
the most important point of all at this
point in our culture what's political
correctness yeah I think when things go
too far one way people get upset with
that and when people get too biased
whether it's towards the left or towards
the right it tends to balance
things out in the other direction like
Robert Anton Wilson called Lyndon
Johnson the pacifist president you know
I called him the pacifist president
because he was such a [ __ ] that he
created so many pacifists because of his
atrocities that he ordered in the
Vietnam War people were so upset that
more people became pacifists during the
Lincoln or excuse me there during the
Lyndon Johnson administration than than
ever before you know by the same token
he called Reagan the intellectual
president because more people just went
oh my god you gotta [ __ ] god damn it
it's important know things yeah
god damn it its support to be smart like
just say no [ __ ] what are you talking
about just say no you're him you're
bringing heroin in from Vietnam just say
no you're selling coke in South Central
to pay for the [ __ ] country this is
really stirs obviously you don't know
though Oliver North story story dude the
real rick ross not the rapper but the
real Rick Ross has been on my podcast
twice was a drug dealer in South Central
who they put away for a life due to the
three strikes rule yeah but became
didn't know how to read okay went to
jail was a drug dealer made millions of
dollars selling coke okay
did not have any idea who was bringing
him the coke Holly was getting and where
was coming from the profits that they
were making was literally paying for
Oliver North to arm the conscious versus
the Sandinistas I mean it was literally
it was all proven in court I mean this
is what my current reconstituted in
front of what was the I forget what the
gathering was but on television on
c-span
Michael Rupert who was a narcotics
officer for the Los Angeles Police
Department who was also been on my
podcast for he committed suicide he was
the guy that was the focus that movie
collapse remember that movie collapse
where he's talking about
remember he in that he it was just him
smoking cigarettes sitting there talking
about what he knew about the economy
what he knew about all these different
things that were
in our society and how there's only a
certain amount of time for its gonna
collapse it was kind of a crazy doom and
gloom documentary but the point is he
had caught CIA agents rogue cowboy CIA
agents in them in the middle of selling
drugs yeah in South Central Los Angeles
reported it and was in trouble because
of that and decided to go public with it
and they were selling these drugs they
were making shitloads of money and they
were transferring the money like to arm
these rebels well Rick Ross was in the
middle of that and didn't know he was in
the middle of that he was literally
selling drugs and funneling this whole
thing went to went to jail as an
illiterate person who could literally
couldn't read learned how to read in
jail became a lawyer jail like leg
learned okay yeah I think figured out
that you can't charge him for the three
strikes rule if it's one thing if it's
if you're charging him with a bunch of
counts under one incident it's the three
strikes law doesn't apply and that's how
they got him in jail so now he's out
like all of this came because of that
well I knew about Oliver North and in
the Contra thing I didn't know about
rick ross specifically well this is this
there's been proof there's some elements
of our government have sold drugs in
pravesh neighborhoods in order to fund
black ops like this is a fact and this
is one of the things that Robert Anton
Wilson was talking about when he was
talking about the Reagan administration
became the intellectual president
because people were so frustrated by how
[ __ ] crazy and chaotic and movie like
you know things had become that they had
decided to arm themselves with
information I wonder if a big part of it
that too is the backlash with Ronald
Reagan because everyone said again he
had no chance he was a [ __ ] and he won
in a landslide if he'll go alright screw
you
we're gonna consider him an intellectual
like with Donald Trump listen I don't
think Donald Trump's intellectual no one
was considering an intellectual they
were considering him a great American
Ronnie had slicked back hair and his
wife stood still and everybody was happy
well being between seances at the White
House her astrologer make a change but I
think people might have just been like
you know what you called him a [ __ ] for
so long and everyone in voted him a
[ __ ] de then well they didn't really
call Reagan a [ __ ] yeah they did well
no
they called George Bush yeah they did
yes I did the PlayBook with with anyone
who's conservative Republican is if they
can make you a [ __ ] they will if not
you're evil right Cheney can't be a
[ __ ] he's evil I think you're confusing
the narrative a little bit cuz well
Reagan might have been simplistic but he
was a wonderful speaker like he he gave
really articulate well-thought-out
speeches that spoke to Americans again
longing for this nostalgia of a time
where the Norman Rockwell painting made
sense right and that's what Ronald
Reagan represents it to a lot of pedia a
lot of people they were you know they
were coming out of the chaos of the
Carter Administration and the [ __ ]
Vietnam and yeah gas lines and the
Iranians taking the American hostages
and all that crazy [ __ ] and Ronald
Reagan came along he's like I'm gonna
fix it I'm your dad never he's like
we're in yeah but the media treat him
like a real [ __ ] if you go back and
watch that and right before his
landslide election win they made if you
look at the the electoral map sort of
the polls and predict predictions they
give him no chance of winning and then
full of [ __ ] about Colorado and traffic
deaths should we go and [ __ ] you up with
this - yeah what do you have a guy
looking to feel bad about the Colorado
thing at all what I never said Colorado
I said states that legalized what other
ones are there well you didn't bring up
the source that I wrote about I can but
the fact that you're still hung up on
please hope please what I got the
article I've been looking at it for like
last few minutes on your website yeah
there's a couple statements that are
really bad just off - just off the gate
like this right here if you want to get
higher or more on hold on please that's
a common battery hold on but fine
after all things like Coachella wouldn't
exist is this your article yeah I think
it's an article on my site Wayne if you
can want to get high you're well you're
a [ __ ] yeah thank you is it you're a
[ __ ] I think who's Courtney she's one
of the best writers I think I've ever
dare you not read then but so the next
article links to a couple like this for
instance is one that says it has
deadliest year of traffic fatality since
2008 yeah this article doesn't say
anything about marijuana not one one
thing doesn't mention me weed at once it
does say that it could be attributed to
crisis people driving
people in the state sure etc etc I'm
gonna defend myself here because you
have someone here at the ready and what
you do is instead of bringing up
information this is what happens with
Christopher Titus right you don't have
information that you bring up you have
another guy look up a source that you
specifically want him to find I didn't
ask him to bring that I brought up
Washington Post and goes this is what's
wrong with your article taking enough
talk you didn't have a joke the joke in
there about the things that Coachella
wouldn't exist if there weren't pop
that's a joke right to try and go do you
think people who smoke are morons no
it's a joke okay and no pots not
comparable to alcohol there are tests
that determine how much alcohol content
is in your bloodstream
we can't you do that with weed so it's
impossible to handle these incidents in
the same way that's okay but there have
been tests where they showed people but
go back to what he said would have been
tests where they've shown people drunk
versus on marijuana and the people on
marijuana drove far better okay that's
true so this is also anecdotal no it
goes that's a your point right let's say
someone has alcohol these tests well I
don't haven't read your test okay so why
don't you arguing against them no I'm
saying I agreed with your point earlier
so why are you saying there I mean what
is anecdotal if you're saying some
people drive better on maro I'm not
saying that I've said there have been
tests what they've shown that people
draw it better on marijuana than alcohol
what anecdote my point is if you looking
to be really good at this argument
settle down you said you wouldn't pile
on and you got two people on the show
when someone comes on the show
Jared can not enter congratulations
you're not on the show and all he did
was pull up and some [ __ ] to mention
bringing up information me without a
laptop no he brought it you said what
would be the one thing that you've
changed your mind is your problem with
two people are correct and you're
incorrect does that bother you I don't
agree that you're correct what are you
talking about you just pulled up some
statistics that showed the Colorado has
less traffic fatalities in statistics
though he did and you can you can track
what is the issue that you would care
about the least that you've changed your
mind I said probably wouldn't even talk
about that's that's a long ver
of what you said well if there been more
fatalities since marijuana has been
legal in those things we've discussed
not true why are you so obsessed with
the pot because you're not right and it
doesn't matter if we've talked about it
for four hours in this instance you are
incorrect you know you're correct in
that instance the traffic fatalities of
increased in areas were part of
increased we did the same study in
Michigan where pot was legalized and
people were actually selling more
marijuana and underage kids I don't
think we have anything to do with it it
doesn't have anything to do with traffic
fatalities unless you can prove there's
more traffic fatalities and underage
kids since marijuana has been legal yeah
there been several articles that have
made that claim made that assertion
what's fine written about it let's find
them they all come from one article
mostly and it's from the triple-a stats
and this is the stats that they said and
I suppose almost all the articles you're
talking about come from this one article
okay okay so this is the percentage of
drivers involved in fatal crashes who
recently used marijuana more than
doubled from 8 to 17 percent from 2014
their 2013 to 2014
one in six drivers involved in fatal
crashes from 2014 had recently used
marijuana which is the most recent data
available now do you understand smashes
involving marijuana pinion it's an
opinion alarming well is that is that a
matter of more people smoking marijuana
because it's legal or it's a met is it a
matter of the marijuana causing these
accidents is this you know what else is
true do you know what else is true that
all these people also had alcohol in
their system do you know that well no
and we don't know that a lot of them
rewind the tape a lot of them well you
made a list let's find out it doesn't
say anything in the article about
alcohol though and for sure this should
have tested that makes a point that
you're gonna have an obvious position
that would disagree with this one single
article so if I can finish a point
you've talked about interruption let me
finish the one point that I'm making
well you read through marijuana you
a chance for marijuana roadside right
can we absolutely can you before you do
that as you said how many of the how
many of the marijuana related fatalities
also involved alcohol because it's a
massively significant percentage yeah so
you can't necessarily say that just
because they have these new tests for
marijuana especially roadsides now the
problem is you can't okay I'll tell you
what I'll give you that what do you give
with me let's say you're correct but
here's the thing let's interact
physiologically it doesn't have an
effect on motor skills the way alcohol
does or it doesn't slow down your
response time well I know we've had
several doctors in the show two of whom
had differing opinions on that they
don't have to be right we have Iranians
of it do they do themselves do they know
what it's like CBS News caught blatantly
distorting cannabis study says the
signals from doubles fatal comes from
mini press news mint press news so again
we can go into questioning sources all
day long if you have someone else bring
them this is a good source maybe this or
something else one issue and you said
what's the issue you don't have your
sources right here I've looked them up
there's people online also sourcing them
they are skewed you're skewing them to
make sure the Washington Post study that
you skewed but you're not the Washington
Post you're supposed to be the answer to
the Washington say that someone's evil
so I'm evil too you just said there's
that way you're so that's the argument
that you just no I didn't mean you just
said come on made that argument and all
of a sudden when someone mentions pot
you put on the rear world view the lens
of we know [ __ ] has nothing to do with
we but you have an argument I haven't
made an argument you said increased we
showed you what have wrote what have you
shown me we showed you the statistics
that show that marijuana and traffic
violations the more links to lay not
because of accident right okay so what
else is causing the drop number and why
can what your reason number what
increase this fake increase from your
brain
it's not real it's not real calicoes
it's not real
so where is it real what was it comes
from as triple a study that was dressed
your glands right
counsel Triple A is owned by the
Bilderberg Group Oh God you don't even
know this so now we're gonna go to we'd
cures cancer and people having meetings
in grams it's got one one article that
says one thing and one article from
Colorado that says there's been a
decrease in traffic fatalities right
you're not willing to recognize that I
just said let's give that to you because
this entire conversation started with
you saying what issue would you change
the mind on no it started a pot because
you know this argument started with you
saying that it causes more fatalities
that's not true you said which issue do
not care about it I say pot and then she
said causes mortality what's your
opinion on pot and I said I really don't
care if people want to smoke pot I think
it's a state issue I honestly don't care
I've changed my mind where as a kid I
thought it was harmful I don't think
it's harmful didn't you say that it
caused traffic fatality you said well
let's expand on this what issue do you
have with pot I said I don't like the
dishonesty where people just say it
cures cancer it'll end the war on drugs
it's it's completely harmless and I have
some arguments to not harm I know it's
not entirely harmless well it's not
without consequences well consequences
because there's so much leeway there how
have you have you started from me saying
I probably couldn't care less about this
out of all the other issues that we
discussed and you lasered in on that and
go where do we disagree
no because a huge blind spot
no it's not huge blind it's deaf don't
have that if you say that marijuana is
in some way or another a dangerous thing
yeah I can tell you that it's no no I
didn't say in a dangerous thing what did
the consequence okay what is what do you
believe marijuana does for example well
no I'm not gonna get baited into this
because you're gonna you're trying to
force me to say that I don't think pot
cures cancer and there's a big forum now
listen smoke pot no that's I will ask
this I'll try to say what the caller you
come on my show right now you're in
front of me right now were stationed you
and I right now oh that's not good to
read snores it's
I'm here to have two people let's face
like before you swing in a room with no
think of Amy and I gang up on you think
you would've done well in that argument
come on man cuz I want to find out how
you feel how you think wife see if you
get defensive for some reason you said
you think if her and I work together you
think you would have done well on that
yeah because I want to see if you get
defensive well in a conversation why
wouldn't you do that right no but you've
made it to hall about the pot issue know
that another do it pod Amy shoot you've
gotten into this pot issue because the
issue and it's the one area you're
adorable you're adorable
and there's something you're so used to
not a real comedian
no you're adorable you're someone on an
open territory without someone else to
back up your argument it's never
happened if it's back up when someone
pulls up information realize is he pulls
up evidence to the contrary if I was
wrong he would stick it right in my face
and we would laugh about it and that's
what he does that's why you pull that
for the contrary and I've given it to
you what evidence you ever give me [ __ ]
no I've given you the argument what I'm
fine let's say there's no there's no
causation let's say that wasn't backed
up well enough let's give you that
argument okay what's this Jamie to
decrease in traffic me doing this stuff
we don't do that this is what we always
do it's just talking about facts solicit
your poll please there are some there
are also some evidence that medical that
doesn't make any sense there are also
some evidence that's naughty that
there's also okay I'm wrong that medical
marijuana laws may contribute to
decreasing traffic fatalities one study
published in the Journal of law and
economics 2013 reviewed traffic
fatalities in the nineteen states that
had passed medical marijuana laws by
2010 and found that legalization is
associated with an 8 to 11 percent
decrease in traffic fatalities for the
year after the laws took effect the
researchers from the University of
Colorado Denver and elsewhere also found
the decrease is more significant for
alcohol related fatalities at thirteen
point two percent a squash the interest
I can ask a question please do why is
that study from 2010 considered
completely valid to you in the study
from triple-a in 2014 considered
completely in this triple A's got a [ __ ]
biased in there you go because there you
go yes company different in charge well
what are they basing it on what so your
argument this is this is the only valid
study because Triple A is but this is a
study you ignore it do you think that's
right I think they're lying
be right I think I'd be right so if
they're right if that studies right then
you were wrong right if that what if
that studies right then they were wrong
right I could be wrong you were wrong
right when you outing it out so we
proved that in Colorado you were wrong
you didn't hear that study is true well
you didn't asked one question and then
you get a you'd like you doing this
don't you Joe
you lied early said I'll give it to you
win the argument and you bring up
another thing about pot well it's
because you don't know you don't really
give up you relax yeah I said I'll give
it to you you're right let's assume oh
yeah you're definitely wrong let's
assume I'm on okay so what else would be
the problem with marijuana if it wasn't
traffic 15/0 right no not zero
what's your buts come on man we're
talking about real issues what would be
the other problems unfortunate Alec
before you go oh man just loosen up
let's talk about life in jiu-jitsu then
you're gonna want then let's talk you're
upset I just want to get you away from
your left versus right talking points
omni cuz love cyclists cuz little people
with conviction or left-right paradigm
Bertrand centrist I kind am Joe you Brad
Joe here's the thing and I started off
very and I still mean the the company
things I said but you can't bring people
on and call them [ __ ] and dumb come on
bro I can't and then continue going back
to an issue and with with someone who
agrees with you entirely and act as
though well someone will not your
defensive well of course some defensive
well I think that you were spewing a
little bit of anti marijuana propaganda
about traffic fatalities I want a pair
of propaganda that's right I'm not
thinking you're paid by anybody but I
just think you had a point of view what
I push the propaganda inanition means I
have to be pushing more necessarily that
someone is telling you to do it it's
just that you had a point again you had
dug your heels in it's not propaganda
it's proper to wrong
it and you are spouting it out but that
statistics proved different well okay
then I would say it's propaganda or
someone saying insane you're yours
cancer I'm not saying you're promoting
up again okay pull that up then yours
can find out with not saying cures
doesn't make you worse cancer nothing to
answer and that was what I was talking
about literally nothing
chores anything I mean things type of
your listeners will tweet me say they're
seniors Rob that cures anything think
street things your immune system system
fails play traffic here okay what what
trolley Oh cures things polio vaccine
okay polio vaccine doesn't cure things
you [ __ ] it prevents you from getting
polio the diseases a few understand what
you just said you just yourself no I
didn't just know that disease is not
effectively cured the person who has
polio we're talking about marijuana
curing cancer on people that don't have
cancer yet that's not what you signed up
faxing for cancer what you're saying is
marijuana cures cancer with people that
have cancer there's not a [ __ ] drug
you proved yourself no I don't like
medicine that proved right that you
can't [ __ ] cure polio with a medicine
you get so aggressive right now you have
a blind spot I'm pretty sure there's
drugs out there that cure some diseases
I'm sure I never heard of him well lady
you know their name one not offhand if I
had someone who could bring it up no you
don't have to bring it up man you're
gonna argue for it shouldn't I do argue
for it I don't think you think that's
incorrect your in your immune system has
to be in place if you are [ __ ] if you're
you like dying and someone gives you
some sort of a drug how many drugs are
there that cure a nasty disease that's
killing you and how many of them have to
be also
compensated your immune system has to
kick in as well there's a bunch of
factors it's not like how many I mean
there's penicillin that kills some some
like venereal diseases and all sorts of
different [ __ ] horrible infections
yeah but there's not a lot but it takes
your immune system has to be an effect
too there's there's a lot of factor
because now we're going to the
definition of cure and
man because you're talking about [ __ ]
polio nothing cures polio [ __ ] and
marijuana no one say in marijuana all
the time [ __ ] this is people that
say you're not see those are same people
that say you're a Nazi now it's pretty
common pretty [ __ ] Nazi punch Nazis a
woman on the show had a woman on the
show a psychiatrist who basically said
she said people who are adult healthy
smoke pot shouldn't Pro not a problem it
is a problem for the developing brain
people who are under the age of 25 she
explained as Hawaii correct and she I
don't think they they think that the
human brain is even fully developed your
fluid some text and she talked about
specifically also people who might have
mental illnesses whether it's
schizophrenia bipolar most people don't
realize that or depression it goes
unrecognized
and she talked about how for those
people marijuana can act as a trigger
mechanism so she said healthy people
none of these conditions marijuana is
probably relatively benign but for some
of these people and most people who
might have these conditions are
afflicted by them it could be a real
problem she's got some very good points
but do you know they are weed cures
cancer this dumb [ __ ] should get off
the show do this cannabis hasn't shown
just kill cancer cells in laboratory
tests see question six you know it
doesn't cure cancer though kill cancer
cells no one's saying cure cancer you
compare it compared it to turmeric you
compare all these things but look the
the point being I think you agree and I
agree that as long as it doesn't hurt
other people any more than anything else
like sugar hurts other people look if
you want to make an argument for high
insurance rates you want to look at the
overall causes of disease in this
country and why insurance and health
insurance cost so much you would almost
immediately go towards simple sugar like
simple sugar is a huge problem with
people who are obese obesity is a huge
issue in this country and it's a major
factor when it comes to health care
costs right I think it's adorable that
you're telling me how to craft arguments
it's it's an easier argument to say that
ice cream should be illegal and is that
marijuana should be illegal no I don't
and I think tell me well now I'm gonna
I'm gonna say what I was about to say
beforehand because you keep redirecting
the conversation and your turn and for
some reason you're turning into
something hostile that it really doesn't
need to cost
it might be to you yeah I didn't feel
weird about it I feel great it is it is
when someone comes in somewhere they
know they disagree and someone ought to
other people the same opinion you're
gonna do it team up he doesn't even have
any I think that look at this what
you're doing right now Joe is like you
talked about with people in jujitsu this
is what I think there are now hundreds
ient if excited say that I think that
you through these arguments were
cannabis cures cancer I think that you
think these arguments work and I think
it's like someone going to jujitsu for
the first time you've never done it I
don't think you've ever actually gotten
to a place without someone who can bring
up sources for you I don't think you've
gotten into an argument or done anything
with a debate team or people would
actually hold you accountable to the
argument that you make I think what
you're saying you don't think that I
have if you don't know what conversation
so what are you somebody with me 24/7 I
think right now you're the kung-fu guy
hitting the the kung-fu doll with the
spikes and you've convinced yourself
that this is an argument that would work
if he had other people more qualified
than myself to discuss it and you
decided ozone in on an art this is a
huge way of you diffusing all these
stats that Jamie keeps bringing up is
more than a hundred studies exactly it
proves that cannabis cures cancer
exactly do you deny you don't need a
judge my Jamie
Jamie's pulling [ __ ] off the internet
specifically about something where I
changed my mind okay you clearly were
ready or upset about the pot down wasn't
nothing about that anymore because I
don't really care about it and I think
states should be able to legalize it if
you don't care about it she [ __ ]
crazy
three follow-up questions if you like me
asking you why you endorsed Bernie
Sanders on the show Nathalie Sonya Tom
he's insane with the socialist stuff I
don't think it's very genuine what
you're doing what Kelly no it's not you
Q started on with traffic fatalities and
I did start on you said what is she's
red and not talked about and this is
exactly why right because we've talked
about nations and always occur that was
one of the things he to this transition
this wasn't it and there's no what if
conversation that comes from it oh sure
there is no for people who are listening
to this is extremely productive because
they understand how someone with
blinders can ignore the evidence sure
and figure out some way where they're
being wronged intellectually someone
like someone will say that oh you should
be in some sort of a debate you've never
been in a debate you don't know what
[ __ ] debates I've been in
no you don't know what conversation with
you and your boy Stephen come on why is
this bullying political there are two
people who hold one opinion asked me on
something that I don't care about
follow-up three four questions to go
into an area where you two are very
specifically passionate and I said I
don't want to talk about it you don't
want to talk about it cuz you're wrong
no I don't talk because I don't care
because he keeps show stage want to
legalize it that's fine but it is a
valid issue when people of Colorado are
looking at this now and there are people
in Colorado who might vote differently
on the marijuana issue because of how
it's perceived or because of the
information at hand and I believe that
people in Colorado should be able to
vote they voted for pot but if they want
to vote the other way in states they
have the right to do that who's arguing
against that well that was my point when
we're talking about marijuana my point
was when I worked at Fox
we were thrust under panels where you
had to talk about this because it was
going on in Colorado I can't believe you
called me a bully that's such a
left-wing town you are how dare you you
are how dare you how dare is how is it
really you are what you use these
absolutes and call smart and then say
well okay let me give you one that I can
pull from my memory thank you all of
them were on alcohol that did [ __ ] that
up
yeah you've done it several times but we
did worse discussion are you doing that
I know is a large number there's a large
numbers is narconon or one of those
company one of those there's there was
one it was unlikely source yeah well you
don't tell me have to leave now like
this I surround well you're gonna miss
your flight no matter what now you're
[ __ ] we're gonna be fine dude I'm not
gonna be fine I'm not gonna make my
flight back yeah you're gonna be fine
you're live in America could be in
Ethiopia right now huddling in a [ __ ]
Hut you know trying to protect yourself
from a some rabid animal yeah don't be
scared we're gonna be fine you got a
little defensive we thought we're
friends did listen I thought we're gonna
have some fun we were having fun and
then toward the end of the conversation
you asked me what does she do not care
about I don't really care about the pot
which I thought I cared about when I was
21 you said you wouldn't defend issues
when you were from when you were seven
seven years ago right on your cells
every well 21 I was probably a lot
harsher on pot than I am today I thought
it was worse I grew up around it I had
negative experiences then I realized
that was anecdotal I don't really care
much anymore I don't think state should
be able to do what they want to do then
three four five follow-up questions so
we could get to a point into this debate
where the show is now going on two three
hours long and I've missed my flight
well you were trying to say was that
people that are pro marijuana ignore the
negative consequence of marijuana and I
asked you what those were right and you
said traffic fatalities one of them and
then we tried to find out if that's true
and we found out it's not didn't find
out that it's not true you made an
argument that it's not true but we
didn't we didn't definitively find out
that it's not true a lot of statistics
well you just it's very easy to do that
when you ignore opposing statistic no
it's fine plenty of time man you're not
gonna get your flight you've got a lot
of time this is this is an interesting
argument right it's an interesting
argument because it shows what happens
when people not necessarily disagree but
getting a new position where one person
wants to have the upper hand and you
keep jockeying back and forth we're
trying to figure out who's gonna wind up
on the top of the heap no there's no
jockeying back and forth now you're the
one jockeying back and forth
sweetie you know honey if that's a [ __ ]
come on [ __ ] that honey
that might be dumb [ __ ] might be
bullying yeah sweetie what you've done
come I did it as a joke cuz I thought
we're friends you don't think when we
talk every now and then I didn't like
you do but you don't think we're friends
you brought me a pipe he gave me a pipe
I did give you a pipe you know my
podcast twice I know I'll fight you back
here's the truth are you upset more than
me
what's more upsetting when you say
you're defensive and you have somebody
else to bring up sources that's let's be
blunt that's it no I don't want you to
look up and Jamie will be let me tell
you something if Jamie found something
that shows me I'm wrong and he does all
the time he pulls it up well not gay
Jarrod no if it is a standing pot on our
show we do it differently
and that's why I invited you on the show
how do you do it differently okay -
comes in the show if Sally Kohn comes in
the show if you come on the show and you
say I want to talk about pot in the show
if you say that and you say I disagree
with you I say okay not gay Jared not a
word and you don't bring up any sources
this is going to be me I'd let him talk
I be like you think I would love Jerry
talks all the time but I don't think
it's fair
why not I would talk to him - I don't
think - one in her argument is fair so
on one you know it's not and if he
disagrees with me and you disagree to me
together we can go back and forth all
together I don't care I don't mind if
there's three people get another friend
that hates pot I don't hate pot well I
mean just a spot I said
mischaracterizations and absolutes there
I don't hate pot I'm not saying you do
I'm saying get a friend who hates pot
break is not our friend who hates pot
get another friend dared get another
friend another Jamie look I should have
used the word also no because the
implication there's another meaning you
hate pot no I said Jo get another person
how to endorse Bernie Sanders and then
had a thing on his face I think it would
imply these arguments I think I gave you
the argument and you continued for
another hour Jo didn't really he gave it
to me with a caveat and that caveat is
that I'm a bully and that Jamie pulls up
statistics and only benefit you are you
are how am i how is it a bully when two
people are talking how is it bully not
two people talking now you don't have a
conversation with two people talking you
have a fail-safe you have other people
who agree with you you have an audience
who agrees with you I'm on your program
talking to my audience man just two
people talking let me be clear okay I
don't hate pot okay I couldn't care less
if you want to smoke pot if States want
to legalize pot okay I couldn't care
less about that now okay
pot is not a substance without
consequence that's all and some of those
consequences can be damage to developing
brain when they're 25 wait a
psychiatrist don't talk about it and
people called her a dumb [ __ ] who you
know and doesn't weed cures cancer
there have been statistics and reports
on fatalities increasing regarding
marijuana you may not accept them and
maybe you're right in those sources
maybe your sources are more Val
than my sources I'll grant you that so
my issue is when people are dishonest
and only present one side of the issue I
just presented several sides and on my
show on a regular basis listen if you
want to smoke pot I couldn't care less
go ahead and smoke pot and I think that
the people who tried to make you think
you know reefer madness and wet and
wacky tabacky I think that's overblown
but I also think there are some issues
that people who simply want to justify
it
sometimes a habit which could be
negative to some people not all
overlooked completely one side of the
issue and there is an entire side of the
medical community who disagrees with you
and I don't know that I agree with them
or disagree with them yet
wait a min the medical community there
is entire side to the medical community
who would disagree with your position my
position no that I that that you think
marijuana is a benign substance I don't
think it's benign to developing brains
we were to discuss that okay a good
example developing brains why I don't
think a lot I think a lot of I would
agree I think a lot of kids listen to I
know you're not responsible it's like
you should be 18 or 18 in Canada you
should be 16 year old to drive a car
you're not telling kids to go and smoke
up but I think a lot of people who are
listening you have many young listeners
who are in that developmental stage
certainly under the age of 25 who only
hear the positive virtues extolled of
marijuana sometimes they're not entirely
honest sometimes they're not entirely
accurate I should say I don't think
that's necessarily a good thing
necessarily accurate how so positive
talked about how harmful marijuana could
be to the developing brain under yeah we
have many time have you in a way that
you've conceded that's valid not we've
said I don't think you should do
anything when I don't think like any 15
year olds to do anything to their brain
because we don't know what the [ __ ]
happens to your brain when you give a
kid alcohol I did it I'm sure you
probably did it too when was it when did
you drink first how old were you
probably 50 first beer quick I think I
was 14 the first time I got drunk with
my friends I mean it's terrible it's not
good for you it's not smart it's
definitely not smart and I know and you
know and I'm sure we all know someone
who did get completely overindulgent in
marijuana and became one of those
wake-and-bake people that ruined their
life and I think people can do that with
almost any substance anything that
psychoactive it
I think people do that with cigarettes
where they do they need that [ __ ]
cigarette more than they need anything I
think a lot of AAA people do that with
cigarettes and alcohol they replaced
their weird addiction to alcohol to
something that's not as bad for them I
think there's a lot of things for the
developing mind particularly for the
developing mind that we have available
to us all the time that are really
dangerous you know and Henry Rollins on
here was talking about when he was a
little kid he was like five year old
they put him on Ritalin yeah the time
was five I think that's [ __ ] horrible
I think psych meds for little kids that
don't necessarily need them but maybe
they're just a little too energetic I
think all that shit's horrible so
whether it's marijuana or alcohol or
quaaludes or whatever you want to give a
fifteen-year-old kid that's got a
developing mind I think there's massive
consequences and I don't think you can
really calculate those consequences
that's my position I think you can
calculate those consequences well I
think you can but I mean you would have
to [ __ ] up a lot of kids in order to
really prove the statistical viability
of what damage is being done to kids and
how much would cause the dead I talked
about ritalin are you talking about
quaaludes alcohol marijuana heroin Lutz
in 2017 Wow quaaludes oxys good school
with oxycontin's I'm just talking about
downer so I'm talking about anything
where it's a depressant or stimulant
there's a significant amount of effects
I think it's just classified as narcotic
it's not like a downer like like a
benzodiazepine or something well aren't
opiates considered a downer considered
barbiturates whether I think there's a
depressant alcohol is a depressant right
calls a central nervous system
depressant
but I know something like like a
quaalude or I'm actually a powerlifter
we're the only drug he could it was a
people not remember this it's a
date-rape drug was a prescribed drug guy
named Chad I'm one of the date-rape
drugs well whatever the most common date
rape drug I don't know if it's I don't
know it's actually roofilin or whatever
it's called but most commonly used or
the most effective date rape sure I know
what you're thinking about but I can't
it's not coming to me I know the drug
but it's it's a weird one where it helps
bodybuilders sleep well there's a
powerlifter yeah yeah power lifters do
it too because it actually infers more
development or growth well not just
growth hormone but recovery time because
they have like deep sleep
[ __ ] what is it called but you know what
I'm talking what is it used as a
date-rape drug rohypnol no not not
that's Rudy's that's roofies there's
another thing I know what you're talking
about is used as a date-rape drug yes
and there was a guy a lot of thing he
could sleep on right and then it became
so they don't prescribe it anymore
he hadn't sound he had like a kid like
an 1,100 squat was quite world record
but close to it and lived out in Reno
Nevada and that was the only way he
could sleep when he wasn't able to get
her anymore
his lifts did you find it fell for Jess
tricks no good no goddamnit
it's got a like a real common name I'll
text my buddy cuz he had an overdose of
it but he was like 18 oh god hold on a
second she talked please where you going
if you go back in the show tomorrow a TV
show or radio your show to do so there's
no way we're gonna get husband's us
making up is gonna be so good for your
show and my show too
no it's not the entire commentary
furnace is gonna be oh what a [ __ ] you
think so we doesn't man don't be don't
worry about it we're gonna be we're
gonna get through this and get through
it in a way that would make sense
lick the rock I definitely get weird
with these conversations last soon
everybody can get you know fake hostile
with me so if I call it come on [ __ ] I
talk to you like that I don't mean it in
a negative I do it like I would do it if
you were Bryan Callen and he would start
laughing along yeah but you live in
Michigan you get a little sensitive when
you go that's adorable when he said
that's not meant to and we were joking
about other topics but on that you
lasered in got serious you're wrong
let's stay on this pound it in that's
that's just it's it's I don't understand
the purpose to it have some fun so
you're at so that's fun fun so you like
doing that you like having you like
having fun agreeing with them what's
going into town yeah a little silly like
I think you might have got a little
silly I like to have a little fun got a
little silly did I did I bring up the
pond issue I said it's the issue I care
about the least come on let's get away
from that we were we're free we're
we're back on the road we're doing good
you just want to grab the wheel yeah
back turn towards the trees don't do it
resist nitro hibiscus cold brew tea it's
tea yeah I had a hibiscus beer recently
what's disgusting they've ever had in my
life and I love hibiscus tea just does
not work for beer I bet if you wearing
Birkenstocks and you what if you had
white dreadlocks you thought this is
amazing
boobies beer you had kombucha
no no kombucha beers so that's like a
kombucha that's like super strong why do
you think I don't know how they do it
because the alcohol with the active
culture in kombucha should figuratively
right there's the alcohol shouldn't it
figured leat it as sugar because of the
way kombucha ferments no not necessarily
because gt's kombucha that you buy at
Whole Foods you have to actually have an
ID to buy it because there's more than
one half of one percent alcohol by
volume so you have to show your ID and
be over 21 in order to buy kombucha
right now that you say that I think I
might have tried kombucha beer once
called can I say the name yeah yeah good
vibrations
mmm and there's one that's okay and one
that literally tastes like there's like
a ginger one and there's like a bit and
one of them I don't de promise they
don't remember which one
so it's rolling the dice every time you
have it see some people I just tell them
about kombucha about the positive
benefits of probiotics and like you
should try it and you should be kimchi
and you should eat I was a kraut
Kieffer's great I had on my own culture
did you ever had a have you ever done
kefir years no no but I did make
kombucha myself I've done that before
kefir is easier really yeah it looks
like it looks like a slimy kind of like
a sea brain or cauliflower is it like a
grain original technically it's a grain
but it's really just an act of culture
of bacteria and yeast so literally as
opposed to yogurt with a straining or
kombucha which it you literally just put
it in a jar put it in on a countertop
for a day and strain it and after I
think about four or five batches it's
doubled and we don't quadruples it's
like an investment account and my wife
killed it well I was on the road
actually doing stand-up I was I had a
few shows and I came back and you have
to replace it every day otherwise
there's no sugar to feed it and came
back and it looks like a snot rag and it
was so that was the end of it not well
buy at the store kombucha is not really
a fungus but it's somehow or another
like a cousin of a fungus and people
think it's a fungus but it's
life-form and when you get it like I had
it at one point in time I was like the
size of a laptop and I had this like big
salad bowl and I was growing kombucha in
my refrigerator in a salad bowl and the
whole top of the salad bowl was this
rubbery sort of life form it's that like
disk name cake but it would get big it
would get really big and then what I
would do is I would drain it into a
pitcher and I would put the pitcher into
the refrigerator and then I would put
more of the sugar water and I forget
what all the ingredients were but I know
sugar was a part of it yeah the culture
had to eat sugar in order to stay alive
and then it would ferment and the
fermentation was a part of it and then
you would you know when you get like
some sort of probiotic benefit from it
that's a lot harder than kefir be free
just poured the milk in the lactose is
the sugar and that's it that's done it's
actually good about it too if you read
the studies on it like two tablespoons
of kefir like actual homemade kefir is
tens of billions you know microorganism
super good for you and it's higher in
protein because if you do the math so
you can still basically at that point
you're left without the lactose so
you're left with really just the fat in
the protein yeah and all the B vitamins
so it's like it's like I read an article
once cannot corroborate this but they
said that goat's milk whole goat's milk
kefir if you could only have one food
would be the most complete food you
could Wow
but what about all your vitamins that
you would get like phytonutrients ideal
it's not idea if you'd only do one cuz
you get the B vitamins you get vitamin D
get vitamin K yeah and that's whatever
they said if you could only have one and
then there was an article said if you
could only have to be like that and egg
yolks have you ever [ __ ] with like
some of those pharmaceutical grade
probiotics like what was Rhonda Patrick
was talking about those once on the
podcast she was talking about some stuff
you have to refrigerate it you buy it is
like super oh yeah I have yeah have you
well you know my producer na cage it had
ulcerative colitis
so Jesus Christ so he's going to our
office bathroom four or five times a day
oh the poor guy and I had a problem one
time right I was so stressed you have
all these nerve endings near my stomach
just I thought like oh no ulcerative
colitis was getting tested for it
and just turned out it was stress and
they put me on these probiotics and it
didn't really work and then when I did
the kefir that actually helped a lot
more would it be ironic if marijuana was
really the cure they needed the entire I
bet you probably would have health
because it would have ease the anxiety I
bet you what if it might have but it
also might have made you more anxious
because it makes people that's one thing
you want to talk about the here's a
negative I'll give you one side of the
negative that people ignore is the
paranoia that marijuana gave it 100%
gives you paranoia I have had some
friends that were deep deep pot heads
that one [ __ ] cold turkey and don't
want to go back it's like a monster
that's in their closet it's rating a
waiting to get them when they go to pick
out their socks there's there's no doubt
about it it has this one effect on some
people particularly if you take too much
of it or if your life is getting away
from you you know if it's like slipping
away from you and then you start waking
bacon and then you just don't ever deal
with all your issues so they compound
and [ __ ] whirlwind but I was told
than you of [ __ ] but my shrinks now
you probably have you done this gene
site testing know what's that really
haven't done it I'm surprised so um it's
mainly used in psychiatry now but
they're saying it's gonna have all kinds
of future with you know determining
cancer and things like that and they
actually use it to look for depression
bipolar or ADHD and they can look at
your genes now I'm not a doctor so I'm
gonna butcher this but basically for me
they can look at your dopamine and say
this is this is how your genetics work
today so if you gay I actually a video
called do you choose to be gay and my
answer is definitively no what if it was
you well I'm again because I don't
choose a pretty much knew when I tuned
into the OSI when I was a kid and I was
looking at Mischa Barton rachel bilson
and the people who wanted to screw Adam
Brody I think that's when you realize
you're gay mm-hmm if it were me then I'd
be gay okay what does that matter just
question would you be uncomfortable okay
no I've had my on the show because I've
trauma minded you quite a bit
thank you you could look rich a tank
well maybe he's gay maybe it ulterior
motives I don't think I would think um
but with dopamine for with me like we
have a relative in the family who
actually well I should say who has an
issue and so they looked at genes that
create serotonin
most people have a long gene in a short
gene and you have two short jeans and
with me that's the case with dopamine so
like a lot of people who would maybe
typically be addicts or people the ADHD
or people who for me I didn't realize
this until I was a lot older
look this is I'm gonna totally expose
myself most vulnerable to all the angry
pot heads after the argument I didn't
realize until I was older I didn't
actually feel the same feelings of joy
for like pleasures other people though
so dopamine right you know how that
works it's you reward center like you do
something good Bing and I was a B
student in high school I never opened a
textbook because if I completed
something I did a project that was it
bones you like I did a project that's
like okay I did a project what's the
next thing I never really felt that
reward center in the brain and they did
this gene site testing and they found it
basically have the worst genetic pattern
it's not entirely accurate but it's
actually increased the efficacy of
antidepressants from like a 1 in a 1 in
to to like a two and three Wow
something like that because they can
look in and look at your genetics more
effectively and so no I'm sorry to
interrupt but no did are you have you
taken anti depressants I've taken ADHD
medication that's not antidepressants
but it's activity disorder is a
completely different situation it's but
it's also basically a dopamine shortage
ADHD is mmm Wow
that's why stimulants you know on people
who actually have ADHD don't rev them up
actually there's own a man you know some
studying and they feel like wired and
before there's nanak testing that's how
they often tested for it as well how do
you react to this drug and if you feel
wired like you know me with all this I
had six noir milligrams of caffeine
right then you probably don't have ADHD
what kind of [ __ ] they put you on when
they put you on ADHD medication you know
the basic like adderall stuff like that
also they put you on adderall I yeah I'm
taking it and I don't I don't take it
every day because I never want to be
dependent on it how often you take it I
don't know ten times a week yeah
probably yeah you just take it down okay
it is amazing I will tell you this I
never realized until I took it and this
is not I'm not advocating cuz I think
it's way over prescribed I think you're
right I think most kids were I don't
think you should put kids on it I think
you're right and I think that most kids
or most people who take it don't need it
but I also think that there are people
with real condition
out there like you that can benefit from
it well you have a genetic well we can
prove it well because for the longest
time my wife will hear this and she'll I
denied it through and through I thought
no you know there's this is just this is
[ __ ] the ADHD just to get kids
whacked out on Ritalin and I you know I
had people I would deal with like
counseling her stuff feels like it would
get stressed I had stress management
issues and like you seem like now no I
don't believe it and then I was given a
book on ADHD and I never never finished
reading it I'm like three pages and
moved on to something else
and they said okay let's do this test
this whole kind of questionnaire deal
and was pretty extensive you know short
of actually doing a cat scan okay you
test like in the top 99th percentile and
we did the gene site testing I think
it's called gene site and it was pretty
remarkable and I will say that I won't
get into exactly what it is that I've
done or what medications I've taken but
it was certainly life-changing as far as
I didn't know what normal people felt
like wow that's really fast and ADHD is
a fascinating form of a sort of a mild
mental disorder that's extremely
frequent I don't think it's as frequent
as a lot of people think that I would
give you I think it's over prescribed I
really do I really do because whenever I
say it you know people go oh I - I'm
major adda I don't know it's not the
same thing right that's the thing that
people like to say to dis compensate for
them being a douchebag Asperger's I'm
sorry I'm on the spectrum but it is I
came into it kicking and screaming and
Wow I mean I never did anything school I
just did the bare minimum I was boring
hmm so boring and then when you know
they started doing actually like you
know tests and you know IQ testing and
stuff and we found it like well listen
medication doesn't make you smarter okay
I have my own theories about this whole
thing that they do when they take kids
and they make them all sit in the same
school in the same class and listen to
the same subject right I don't think
there's anything in life that mirrors
that and I think experiences in life
vary radically and I think that if you
looked at nature and the great spectrum
of survivors and you know winners and
losers and how
genes get expressed and how evolution
takes place in nature yeah there's all
sorts of different kinds of animals
why wouldn't we assume there's all sorts
of different kinds of people whenever
you force all people to sit down and do
the same thing you're gonna have
aberrations you know people that don't
like obviously you've found something
with your show and with public speaking
that you you excel at like you found
this thing like this ranting thing that
you could do we could just go on a
hundred words a second about all these
different things like you found this
thing where whatever way your brain
works yeah it works perfectly for that
it's the same thing with a stand-up
comedian the same thing with a musician
an author there's a lot of people that
daydream all the time like all your
[ __ ] loser no right this guy's
writing books and it's [ __ ] head
just give him a goddamn laptop and he's
gonna make a million bucks yeah you
don't I mean it's like I mean and the
truth is people they want to know you
probably talked about this with
Christina Hoff Sommers actually there
are people who have a lot of those kind
of interactions that you talked about in
the classroom on a daily basis they're
called women they sit down and talk
think about women they get together with
a book group whatever it is they
literally sit down and listen and
they'll listen to someone and that's it
and they'll sit because they're very
auditory that's the way they learn the
public education system in United States
was designed for girls from the ground
up and you put boys into a world where
they don't do well they do not thrive in
that atmosphere of what girls do
and that's why girls have much higher
grades in high school going into college
and then when boys can study at their
own pace they do better on the SATs
that's a great book called wild at heart
I think by John Eldridge that talks
about that and this is a long time ago
talking about then rather we know boys
learn better with their hands think
about it right it's considered a
masculine gym shop or not just masculine
things but physical science where you're
working in a laboratory those are
subjects where boys actually tend to do
better than girls often in high school
or they rate it as something they like
instead of changing the way we do male
education we try and change little boys
and that's a real that's a real problem
and I think that's a big reason not
because someone was bullied because
someone used the word [ __ ] I think you
probably a lot of incidents of
depression and young boys in particular
because you're putting them in an
atmosphere where they can't possibly
succeed yeah well I think both are
problematic but I think the square peg
round hole issue has been there for the
beginning of school in the first place
and I I don't mean to be like a
proponent of homeschooling but really
every I mean once you have kids I think
you kind of realized that god damn every
kid out of the box is a totally
different thing they're just different
yeah we're gonna homeschool because my
wife she went to Montessori School and
she went to was a public high school or
private high school but she's basically
she's a genius she's very very smart but
she did not do well in a normal school
at all at all do you think you could
find a school that maybe is more
flexible or a because the Montessori
School socializing is critical for kids
and socializing during the day where
they learn about each other you know
they learn about interactions and you
can talk to them too they come home you
know Debbie said something mean to me
what did she say yeah you know I mean I
think that's important I can tell you
kind of a tale of two homeschooled kids
I have I won't give any names here
because I have okay family they have
homeschooled kids very weird just stare
at the screen all day I have another
family friends who were homeschooled
they're kids they're the best kid you
could possibly have an adult dinner
table because they put the kids in
jiu-jitsu I think one of them does
tennis they put kids in all kinds of
social activities they travel with the
kids they take them to Europe and then
whenever they have adult get-togethers
where it's appropriate for kids to be
they still have adult night and date
night kids can be there and they'll
speak when asked to speak they don't
interrupt they're able to interact with
adults they're probably the most
well-adjusted kids I've ever seen and
then I have seen the weird creepy
homeschooled kids where you do your
class on your iPad and then afterwards
you get to watch PewDiePie you know play
video games or whatever it is so it
really does come down to the parents but
I do think that a parent who knows had a
home school kid I think that's gonna be
a specialist the mama's at home with the
kids you know I think it's a huge leg up
well there's obviously so many variables
as far as the intellect of the parents
and what their thought processes behind
homeschooling their kid and what their
experience level is and how much thought
they put into it and where where they're
coming from emotionally psychologically
intellectually yeah there's a lot of
variables I mean the idea of
homeschooling is bad or homeschooling is
good I have friends that have
homeschooled three of their kids they
have four kids a home school three of
them the kids are
fine yeah they're fine they put a lot of
work into it they spend a lot of time
with their kids they took their kids all
over the world they took their kids
traveling all through Europe yeah you
know they just decided at some point in
time and it wasn't always home school
they had done some public school they
had done some private school and then
they got to a point they were like look
like what are we what are we doing here
like we're trying to you know the kids
got older into there like preteens and
then they're teens and then they came to
this conclusion like what what they're
coming back from high school with and
from middle school with is not what I
want them to be exposed with I want a
two brother I want to be exposed to the
classics I want them to be exposed to
life and let just looking at human
beings in a way that's like open minded
and traveling and seeing things and so
instead of like necessarily just having
them take Spanish they lived in Spain
for a little while they went to Spain
and live there late interesting [ __ ]
crazy Asian you were talking on Tucker
Carlson she's a middle school teacher
yeah think of the enclaves of crazy
places where these social justice
warriors go and often they go into
teaching because it's their way to get
power of these little kids here's the
thing that was really we brought about
that on the website and what I wrote
about that does that interview yeah
whatever de bout that was this is a
horrible interview because she's okay
with violence in Berkeley but what
really disturbs me is every other
professor out there who isn't a national
story let's say she didn't get caught on
camera hitting a guy with a stick right
but some kid stands up who's a
conservative in middle school I was that
way where I would argue was a teacher
and just as why I think you're wrong and
she kicks that kid out of class and just
says that kids being disruptive and or
if that let's say that teacher is the
principal gets the kid expelled from
school these people have these little
enclaves of power these positions of
authority and parents kind of have to
trust the teacher so you see that it's a
national story she's exposed but what
about all the teachers who aren't I had
a teacher complained to my parents and
talk about how disrespectful I was and
what a horrible person it was because I
think in the ninth grade I actually
argued I was like I actually don't think
we should give the land back to the
Native Americans but she was too I'm
with the teacher [ __ ] you argument
argument what did you say
while I was a smartass so this was me as
you know at 14
year-old right I said the fact that I
remember that who shoe I won't use her
name I'll say the fact that you're
wearing Levi's and because you have a
sore throat you're speaking to an
electronic speaker when you dress drove
here in a Toyota Yaris and you're gonna
like electric electrically powered
school in a union tells me you're glad
that we settled here and she just she
didn't answer
she'd an argue she just sent me out of
class and Kyra member the next morning I
thought it was kind of I didn't really
think my dad was furious cuz he got a
call from someone saying I was
disrupting class or she asked students
was you get mad at the teacher no he's
mad at me well how was he mad at you no
because he didn't get the full story
just you know this here's my Stevens
being immensely disrespectful right
talking back in class he didn't hear the
she asked for an opinion this was MRE
moral religious education was a class
way to take in moral religious education
yep so there's guilt for the First
Nation people up in Canada is that what
it is this is just specific professor
and a matter of fact I learned what
right-wing was because I remember at one
point said that's so right-wing that's
so right and I didn't know what it was I
was 14 I had said something and I said
dad what is right-wing mean he says well
and he kind of explained to me the
political spectrum I said okay I guess I
am right-wing
I was in Alberta and I was with some
friends who live up there and we were
fishing and we were fishing right next
to these First Nation people which is
their Native Americans right and they
have a limit of walleye that you can
take you can only take one walleye per
day right if you're a regular person but
if you're a First Nations person you
could just yeah pull in as many as you
want and and and I was like how does
that work and they go oh it's way
crazier than that they can go out at
night with spotlights
and shine them on moose and gunned them
down from trucks because then it frees
them yeah yeah they don't know what it
is no stand still they try to figure out
what the what's going on most don't see
spotlights right ever in the real world
so yeah so when they see when they
freeze then they shoot them with guns
from trucks and I was like what
so they're allowed to poach it's not
poaching they can do whatever they want
like well how many of them out to kill
as many as they want so they can kill
all the moose they can kill all the most
Wow
I was like what that is that seems that
seems I you know he makes a great
argument the Native American case is
actually have you read Chael Sonnen book
no it's very interesting and he talked
about this like Michael Medved and
Dennis Prager have talked about this but
I was surprised as to how cogent
Steele's arguments were he's a very
smart guy well he's a very smart guy and
then he always kind of played he plays
it down or plays it up when it's
convenient if you read his book he talks
about he says it's just a numbers game
the reason that we were able to colonize
here is entirely because of Native
Americans they were being he wrote about
it in a way I'm butchering it but he
said like when we came for example like
let's talk about the Mayans because they
had literally pyramids are Aztec
whatever they had buildings entirely
full of cold he goes now how do you
think they procured said gold do you
think that they maybe went to other
tribes or other members and said you are
going to bring us this coal gold or B
die and so what happened was thousands
upon thousands tens of thousands maybe
hundreds of thousands said when the
conquistadors came who would never have
had enough to take over that that area
of the world said we're gonna take our
chances with the red guys with the
beards and the metal helmets because
I've been treating so poorly for so long
and the same thing if you look at the
Algonquin in the Iroquois and Quebec
those were the tribes that we had and
the kind of the the packs that they
would haven't listened they screwed them
don't get me wrong they really screwed
them with the fire water thing and they
pulled the rug out from under them I'm
not defending it but the idea that we
came in and just conquered these people
know there were a lot of people who were
mistreated because this horse culture
that they did it first off they hadn't
domesticated horses they didn't even use
the wheel and so a lot of the things
that that were taught are not true when
were tucked they were peaceful no they
weren't peaceful that's why all of a
sudden these new people who came in with
sticks that go boom had thousands of
Native Americans at their disposal who
were willing to die with them because
they were tired of being treated that
way
and I made some arguments maybe that
effect got in trouble got sent home well
it's a complicated issue that spans
hundreds of years but there was
certainly intertribal warfare and the
word that the Sioux use they don't use
the word Sioux they use the word Lakota
they call themselves Lakota people Sioux
is a word for enemy that's what it means
so like that's what other Native
American cultures would call them they
would call them the enemy because they
were killing each other the Nez Perce
and the Apaches they would go to war
with each other neighboring
it was constant it's just when the
Europeans came they were so overwhelming
that we feel bad for what they did but
you know what killed more Native
Americans than anything our diseases
yeah our dirty dirty bugs yeah we came
over here and coughed on them they all
[ __ ] died well that's another thing
too right that we killed them
deliberately with smallpox blankets
that's not true that's not true we
didn't we didn't even understand we
don't have germ theory they didn't
understand they didn't they didn't
understand that scabs if you like take
you leave the idea was he took scabs
from people with [ __ ] diseases and
you put them on blankets and you gave
them Native American he rubbing your
hands no that's a big thing with horses
yeah they hadn't domesticated horses and
a lot of animals mm-hmm so think about
that you've never come in contact with
these animals they're in the wild and
all of a sudden these people are coming
off effectively with a boat that's a
giant farm mm-hmm and they're bringing
these animals in that you've never had
contact with before all kinds of
diseases
oh sure well that's the thing that
people a lot of people who don't
understand where diseases come from a
giant percentage of them come from our
livestock right that's why you have
swine flu and avian viruses and all
those different things yes ours in the
Toronto Airport only Canada SARS he was
right back SARS you the only ones who
had SARS what was it was it would it
stand for I don't remember his new SARS
I knew all the illusions were wearing
those masks at the Toronto Airport
I remember SARS yeah about Ebola was
just a year ago but it's [ __ ] we're
gonna die Ebola that [ __ ] chick from
New Jersey that [ __ ] she she left the
hospital right there's so much flak from
conservatives too because I was like
listen I don't leave Iraq Obama was the
president but you can't blame a bowl on
the guy freakin diseases from Kenya I
know you know and that's one of those
things where I know I'm seen as an
ideologue but sitting we get so much
flak for criticizing Donald Trump for
example on on some trade policies really
I just think this is bad what's the big
thing that you've been criticized about
Trump for that I've been criticizing
your show just for criticizing him at
all anything and you know the line yeah
people get real because versus them bro
well cuz you know there used to like
you've had people on the show you've
even mentioned in this program people
who are their only their only way his
own death right as being a being a
provocateur to offender and there's
there's a purpose to that there's but if
just defending
people as the end goal and I really
don't think that's what we do if people
actually watch the show
I mean people actually watch the show
every day an hour of content most of it
is really pretty reasonable they see the
highlight reel of me dressing as a
[ __ ] interviewing Wendy Davis right
right that's from thousands and
thousands of hours of the program so we
criticize him all the time but you know
less and less because every time he does
something stupid the left does something
so bad
so we're it's like calling him literally
Hitler like that woman who was this
schoolteacher who's talking about well
the poor Jim Jeffries really bothered
with the woman who's a schoolteacher was
she was talking about that just just
labeling they're all fascists and you
have to stop fascists and then when he
described when he asked her what is a
fascist
she gave like this [ __ ] definition of
what a fascist is it only suited her
need yeah let's pull up the actual
literal definition of fascist young
Jamie what is the literal definition of
fascist as I interpret it it is I did a
video on this and here's what's so funny
if I'm not mistaken Google's definition
brings up fascism and mentions
right-wing but if you bring up communism
or socialism maybe its authoritarianism
something that's very clearly left-wing
they don't actually mention left-wing
okay an advocate or follower of the
political philosophy or system of
fascism he went to Spain to fight
against a fascist to extreme right-wing
yes extreme right-wing a rightist or the
military coup throughout the old fascist
regime synonymous authoritarian
totalitarian dictatorial see this is
where it gets weird cuz undemocratic a
liberal no type in communism but
Authority but hold on a second yeah and
totalitarian like this when you talk
about extreme left-wing ideologues you
are talking about authoritarians and
you're talking about totalitarian yeah
and you're also talking about people
that would advocate violence against
anyone who does not fit their mold of
how a person should think or behave and
what they do is they call them a fascist
or they call you man nazi and that lets
them alleviate themselves of any guilt
of being a violent person against these
people and that's what happened at
berkeley and that's
this woman felt no irony about being on
television saying that Milo is a
homophobe when he's a gay guy well and
she was also tell about justifying
beating up people who weren't Milo Jamie
gasps could you hit a Thor terian real
quick yeah okay favoring or enforcing
strict obedience or authority especially
that of the government of the expense it
was the Phantom now do me a favor type
in communism and I want you to see the
Google so that just said right-wing
extremism right with fascism which is
not a right-wing ideology and only
communism do we all agree is an
inherently left-wing ideology yeah well
a political theory derived from Karl
Marx well there's a lot of like I had
Jordan Peterson on the podcast you know
we talked about how it's like
progressives who are sensitive and kind
people gradually gravitate towards
Marxism in a lot of ways because the
initial draw seems appealing advocating
class war and leading to a society in
which all property is publicly owned and
each person works and is paid for
according to their abilities and needs
so here's the point and I wrote about
this I think we did a video on this
fascism which is not inherently
right-wing at all no it's not they write
right-wing extreme right-wing a liberal
communism which inherently has to be
left-wing it is the definition of the
political spectrum of left-wing would-be
communism and then capitalism and then
in between can be authoritarian
Impressionism depending on the regime no
mention of left-wing with communism
because I know there's a this is Google
they know there's negative connotation
it's the first thing that comes up but
fascism authoritarianism they
immediately try to attribute to the
right hmm that's what people are
fighting back again with when they talk
about media and fake news and the
constant bias you see if there was
Google that's not fair right do you
think there's a problem with also
defining things in terms of a word like
Marxism or like communism like let's
just talk about like what are you trying
to do like what are you actually trying
to appeal to when you're saying that you
can't have someone speak at your
university if they say things that you
don't agree with like do you remember
this story about the University of
Toronto really famous story guy who is
an author they completely misrepresented
what his book was about they were saying
he's Pro rape culture and these
feminists shut it down they pulled fire
alarm
the famous red-haired lady who's been
screaming at people I remember her name
Melissa click I'm Melissa click no no
that's the one from the University of
Missouri I'm talking about the one from
Toronto who is like this like she's kind
of funny in a way because she was like
shut up [ __ ] I'm talking she the RAM
of that yeah I mean that was that was
this crazy moment in time where this guy
had scheduled an appearance to speak
about his book yeah and someone had
misrepresented his book decided what his
book was actually all about and decided
that they were gonna have a campaign to
make sure this guy couldn't talk yeah so
people would show up and they would try
to just go to listen to this guy talk
and women were screaming in their face
you know [ __ ] rapist you piece of
[ __ ] yeah the guy's like I want to hear
the guy talk
can I hear the guy talk no they wouldn't
let people know mean that is fascism
well yeah isn't it well it happened to
with Ann Coulter in Toronto I remember
and whether you agree with her she
deserves I disagree with mine but she
was a member she was asking me like what
and I said well you understand freedom
of speech doesn't really exist in Canada
as my record doesn't exist outside of
the United States
it really doesn't exist in Canada I mean
they have some weird rule doesn't exist
in Europe No and when I told her that
she couldn't and then actually someone
went on news on the news and said well
what Ann Coulter needs to understand is
that America has this idea of free
speech and rugged individualism and all
speech is protected but that's not the
case in Canada and this was the
representative they trotted out where
she basically said freedom of speech
does not exist in Canada and so you can
read the YouTube comments where every
time I see the freedom of speech doesn't
exist in Canada
thousands of people that's [ __ ]
because they think they get to type in
an Internet message board but you can be
jailed in Canada for saying something
wrong you can lose your business there's
a human rights council yeah we talked
about it actually did you have yeah no
but we talked about but he's got a
different case that's from Montreal we
talked about the comedian from Vancouver
that had the altercation with the
lesbians in the crowd they were hacking
him and the comedians before and he
called them some [ __ ] you
pussy-eating dykes or whatever he said
something crazy and they showed him and
won they won yeah he had pay I don't
know if he's paid but he it was tens of
thousands of dollars I think I was like
something like fifteen thousand dollars
this [ __ ] guy had to pay to these
people were
yeah I know that people and you know
that's why again we're people to the
left versus right this is why it does
matter because I lived through it in
Quebec so in Quebec we only have the
left we have liberals and then liberal
separatists that's it there's no there's
liberals and those liberals who want to
only speak French and secede from the
rest of Canada yeah exact connects a
weird place right it's a very weird
place it's not like the rest of Canada
its multiculturalism gone awry the
French were a conquered people it should
have been shut up you're speaking
English instead they said it's cute
let's let them have their little Enclave
and now it's just a nightmare for the
rest of that's where white golfers are
afraid about with California is that
what that means are you just gonna
dominate and turn this whole thing into
a Mexican speaking joint I don't know
what we were talking about yeah the left
versus right because yeah I do think you
do one a certain point I think a lot of
people are readily acknowledging now
that those stories that you're talking
about the red-haired girl the Melissa
click yes Asian lady you really can't
find that today on the right right does
exist on the right and those exist like
that what doesn't exist period on the
right you know people try to point to
like at parental advisory lyrics and
stuff and he probably has to pee as
badly as I do oh my god an angle P that
was typical what ya know the parental
advisory thing from the 80s when they
were trying she was trying to ban rap
music never forget about that Al Gore's
wife yeah was trying to ban rap music
and Christians never wanted to ban South
Park some thing where they talked about
they said no we don't we just don't want
it on it not we wanted on late at night
we don't want our kids watching it never
met Ray Parker and Matt Stone was it
Matt stone him a stoner Trey Parker I
saw Matt speak at UT and he just a guy
stood up and he was like asking this
question I can t fight against these
Christians and he actually said he said
well you know and he said we've actually
never had an issue really he said they
don't want it on in primetime we don't
want it on in primetime we've seen them
as an ally it's he said contrast that to
the Comedy Central reaction where they
decided to cut an episode because we put
Mohammed in it and that tells you who's
really in power right something's that
effect but the kid who was at UT you
know in Austin my brother went to UT so
he would get access to all these
speeches or presentations the kid was
dumbfounded he thought well Matt stones
not one of me and that stones not a
conservatives not a Republican he's not
a trump supporter right he just
recognizes the intolerance today of the
progressive left well there's definitely
an issue when you have that woman the
Melissa Glick lady who is yelling at
that kid who was just a for tahg or
for he was a journalist yeah and I think
he was hired to be there in a public
space who's Asian yeah he's taking
pictures and she said can they can we
get some muscle here cuz we've created a
safe space you tank can't take photos of
our protests and our sit-in and our safe
space about racism so we're gonna get
this Asian guys II don't understand
black America like what the [ __ ] how
long do you think she was waiting to say
I just want to use the term muscle oh
man she was just gonna say get some well
she was intolerant in that she was very
adamant about getting her way and she
did not consider whether or not they
were in a public place and this kid had
the right to take those photographs and
again like you said this an Asian kid I
mean this is not like some [ __ ] white
jock with a crew-cut like from you know
back to the future we didn't say oh it's
[ __ ] Biff
[ __ ] him you know it wasn't that it was
it was like it was really hard to label
him as an oppressor she still found a
way and it was such an Asian response to
where he was just like I just want to do
my job I don't want to be the center of
this story this camera up above us you
know I don't want to start a March like
you have to get out of here he's like no
I don't know this is my job I'm paid to
be here I have to be you have a public
thing going on here there's a protest
after urinate so bad go do it dude go do
it you're gonna keep doing the show no
we'll wrap up let's wrap up alright
let's wrap up
alright so s Crowder on to I'm glad we
got through this dude no you see I
treated you like a stand-up comedian I
figured you'd [ __ ] with me back and get
a little bored fine we got a back we got
through it yeah we got no I'm listen
seriously and for those listening
honestly I won't I don't because I don't
want you to get in trouble if I say
behind the scenes Joe has done some
things he's said some things have been
very nice so he's a nice he you know I
don't know if that hurts your street
cred of like no I don't have zero street
cred well people I like I have cats if
cats have no street cred dude I take
yoga he's a good dude to folks we're all
fine we're gonna be [ __ ] we're gonna
find a way all these ideas to come
together this is part of it this is part
of it
so thank you very much thanks for tuning
in thank you steven crowder thank you
everybody see up [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]